[Musique]
messieurs dames bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle surview nous
sommes en direct est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ise oui je
m'appelle ISEN je suis avocate au
barreau de Paris je suis militante au
sein depuis 15 ans maintenant et j'ai
été présidente de l'association anticors
de 2020 à avril
2024 Ines oui moi je suis Ines Bernard
je suis la déléguée générale d'anticors
je suis avocate de formation également
et j'ai rejoint l'association il y a
quelques années et j'ai pris le poste de
délégué général il y a un an Paul et
Paul CIA je suis enseignant en droit à
l'université et je préside l'association
depuis 7 mois désormais quelle
université une université de parisienne
et vous pouvez pas dire laquelle de non
université parisienne d'accord donc on
vous reçoit ce soir pour parler 120
milliards de corruption qui s'en met
plein les fouilles et comment on fait
pour handendiquer tout ça et pourquoi
ces gens font ça et quelles sont les
plus gros scandales et comment on peut
essayer d'amener des des éléments pour
pouvoir renflouer les caisses pour que
les caisses puissent approvisionner le
budget de l'hôpital le budget de
l'Éducation nationale le budget des
choses simples peut-être là défense qui
est-ce qui veut commencer
éise inè Paul oui on peut déjà commencer
avec le le chiffre parce que vous avez
dit 120
milliards en fait c'est probablement
pire que ça parce que depuis qu'il y a
eu ce rapport parlementaire de l'Union
européenne qui a chiffré la corruption
non pas seulement en France mais dans
toute l'Union européenne mais pour la
France à 120 milliards par an il y a eu
un rapport notamment de LAFA qui est
l'agence française antiorruption qui
nous dit que les infractions à la
probité et les infractions financières
ont ont augmenté de 28 % entre euh 2016
et 2021 h donc on peut pas forcément
dire que mécaniquement on prend le
chiffre de 120 milliards et qu'on
l'augmente de de 28 %. peut-être qu'il y
a quelque chose de positif aussi
là-dedans peut-être que finalement les
les infractions à la probité sont
davantage poursuivi euh peut-être en
petite partie grâce à à l'action
d'anticorps mais on peut quand même pas
nier que le phénomène est est pas en
train de diminuer et qu'au contraire il
a il a pris de l'ampleur en France B oui
en tout cas c'est c'est comme tu le
disais llise c'est des infractions qui
sont extrêmement difficiles à chiffrer
parce que par définition elles sont
toutes occultes c'est-à-dire que on en a
connaissance qu'à partir du moment où
elles sont révélées mais elles ne sont
pas elles sont elles sont révélées en
fait relativement rarement donc voilà on
peut on peut considérer que le chiffre
le chiffre est sous-estimé quelque chose
qui peut être aussi assez éloquent c'est
de se dire que euh 65 % des citoyens de
l'Union européenne considèrent que la
corruption est répandue dans leur pays
donc en tout cas il y a un sentiment de
corruption qui est important chez les
citoyens de l'Union européenne de la
France qui est lié au phénomène de
corruption et nous à anticorps on a
envie de dire bah que on a conscience
que la majorité des des élus ne sont pas
corrompus mais le fait que certains le
soient euh en fait ça ça pénalise et ça
ça ça pénalise la majorité des élus et
surtout c'est extrêmement dangereux pour
la démocratie parce que ça ça met à mal
la confiance des citoyens dans
l'ensemble des représentants ça c'est
hyper embêtant Paul alors je vais
rebondir sur ce que vient de dire Ines
l'immense majorité des agents publics
l'immense majorité des élus ne sont pas
corrompus ont un usage normal de leur
fonction et des fonds publics qui leur
sont confiés il y a une frange il y a
malheureusement une frange très
marginale euh d'élus ou d'agent public
qui utilisent mal l'argent public ou qui
le détourne de leur fin et toute cet
argent qui est mal utilisé ou qui est
détourné de sa finalité pour assouvir
des besoins privés c'est de l'argent en
moins pour le fonctionnement des
services publics c'est un détournement
de fonds publics c'est des impôts qui
sont détournés de leur objectif et
anticorps on cherche à limiter ce
phénomène qui nous nuit à tout le monde
qui nuit à l'ensemble de la société on
cherche à le détourner à à l'empêcher en
faisant des actions euh bien sûr devant
le juge mais aussi on va reparler
sûrement des actions de type préventif
on essaie de d'éveiller à une culture de
la probité et bien bien du courage euh
on va parler de tout ça de la corruption
des élus des industriels des agents de
terrain du spectre où se trouve la
corruption si c'est la upper upper class
ou si c'est euh à l'échelle local ou si
c'est à tous les échelles on va parler
du fait que les fondamentaux de notre
économie sont tous en train de calancher
donc c'est un peu le phénomène de la mer
qui se retire donc on voit qui est-ce
qui est corrompu parce que les
phénomènes de corruption ça existe
depuis la romantique il y a toujours de
la corruption mais quand l'économie va
bien on la repèd moins facilement où on
est peut-être moins besoigneux pour
aller chercher qui tape dans la caisse
qui détourne le pognon et qui fait quoi
avec alors c'est sûr que c'est plus
facile de les attraper quand ils
s'inscrivent avec leur indemnité
parlementaire sur des sites de rencontre
où qu'il se font payer des boîtes de
cigares ou des petites choses comme ça
bon des avantages qui se chiffrent déjà
par dizaines de de milliers d'euros mais
ça devient plus problématique quand
c'est des marchés publics quand il y a
des rétocommissions quand ça finisse les
ça finit et ça finance les partis
politiques que il y a des acteurs
intermédiaires qui peuvent se servir et
on peut se retrouver avec certains
politiques avec des valises de CH en
départ pour Bruxelles ou en départ pour
Genève je sais pas si vous vous rappelez
de cette histoire de notre bel apollon
ambassadeur qui s'était fait attraper
sur le quai de la Guerre du Nord avec
des valises de pogon c'est c'est c'est
quand même il y a pas si longtemps que
ça
inè première question euh l'expertise de
du chiffre de la corruption on fait
comment pour l'avir comment vous
récupérez vos chiffres ça se passe
comment est-ce que Bercy est-ce que
Bercy est euh relativement motivé est-ce
que votre agrément euh euh pour aller
euh en justice pour l'intérêt général ça
a été compliqué pas compliqué vous
l'avez eu vous l'avez pas eu qui qui a
été l'histoire on écoutera Paul nous
nous parler de cette petite P péripétie
Ines ouais la corruption c'est bon euh
le siraise euh comment on chiffre alors
c'est pas nous qui le qui le chiffrons
Anticor on est bien incapable de
chiffrer le phénomène de la corruption
puisqueen fait on en voit que la partie
émergé finalement c'est les signalements
que nous on reçoit nous on est une
association citoyenne on reçoit une
quinzaine une vingtaine d'alertes par
jour et on a une équipe de juristes qui
analyse en fait ces alertes et donc à la
suite de cette analyse juridique on voit
s'il y a à notre sens des infractions à
la probité qui sont qui ont été commises
ou pas et ensuite on s'engage sous
réserve du vote de nos administrateurs
dans des procédures c'est-à-dire qu'on
saisit des procureurs ça c'est possible
que si on nous signale les faits mais on
na pas la capacité de chiffrer tout
toutes les tout le phénomène de
corruption d'infraction à laprité qui
est commis en France et dont on n pas
connaissance qu'on nous signale pas donc
nous on a pas la possibilité de de voir
ce chiffre on s'en réfère comme vous l'a
dit Élise juste avant au chiffres de
l'Agence Française antiorruption qui
établit un certain nombre de statistiqu
encore une fois uniquement euh par par
rapport au bah au aux plaintes qui sont
déposées aux signalements qui sont
déposés en fait s'il y a pas de plainte
s'il y a pas de signalement s'il y a pas
de mise en mouvement de l'action
publique s'il y a pas de lanceur
d'alerte aussi qui ont le courage
d'aller nous parler de de ces choseslà
les infractions elles demeurent occulte
et elles sont pas dans le chiffrage nous
voilà Elise les alertes c'est des gens
de terrain c'est des gens qui veulent
aussi se faire rémunérer est-ce que
c'est des ennemis deux qui balancent qui
qui quelles sont les sources primaires
euh de ces alertes et ensuite comment la
décision
d'aller en
justice prise Anticor en fait il y a
tout dans les alertes il y a aussi des
gens qui vont pas forcément bien donc on
fait un un filtre on écarte des des
alertes qui sont qui sont loufoc qui
sont pas é des règlement de compte bah
les règlements compte c'est c'est un cas
qui est différent si vous voulez parce
que autant on écarte les alertes qui
sont loufoc parce qu'il y a pas
d'élément de de preuve nous on travaille
que sur les preuves hein on va
évidemment pas saisir un procureur de la
République s'il y a pas de preuves dans
le dossier donc la première chose qu'on
fait c'est demander des preuves aux
personnes si les personnes nous
répondent pas qui nous envoient pas de
preuve qui nous expliquent pas pourquoi
bon bah les alertes sont écartées hein
on va pas
et la la la deuxième catégorie qui va
être des personnes qui sont intéressées
peut-être parce que c'est des opposants
politiques on va pas forcément écarter
le dossier parce que nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est la qualification pénale
d'une infraction en revanche on va faire
très attention par rapport au lanceur
d'alerte quiinstrumentalise pas
l'association au-delà de ce qu'est notre
travail à nous qui est de qui est de
s'assurer que les infractions à la
probité sont jugées que les élus sont
pas des super citoyens qui bénéficient
d'une quelconque
impunité mais voilà on va pas forcément
écarter ces alertes là ça pas de sens si
une infraction si on pense qu'une
infraction a été commise et ensuite le
cheminement bah on a une équipe salarié
qui est dirigée par Ines on a trois
salariés qui sont juristes actuellement
et euh il sont payés combien tu veux
dire combien tu payé oui bien sûr s sans
aucune moi je suis payé un peu plus de
3000 € net euh du coup pour diriger
cette équipe de 5 personnes et les les
juristes sont payés plutôt aux alentours
de 2000 2500 € Elise fini alors donc
cette équipe juridique est hyper
compétente exceptionnelle traitent ces
alertes là ils font donc ce travail de
demander les pièces ils montent des
dossiers et une fois qu'ils ont monté
des dossiers ils font des fiches
d'analyse qui peuvent faire deux pages
qui peuvent faire 5 pages qui parfois
font 10 pages tellement les dossiers
peuvent être compliqués pas dans la pas
dans la qualification pénale mais dans
les faits et et ensuite cette fiche là
est envoyée au bureau d'anticorps donc
qui est le noyau dur de l'association
qui est un bureau qui est élu par le
conseil d'administration pour diriger
l'association et le bureau fait un autre
filtre c'estàdire qu'il
vérifie que le dossier est bien étayé il
vérifie la qualification pénale il
vérifie l'intérêt symbolique aussi
parfois et le bureau et l'organe qui
décide de mettre à l'ordre du jour des
réunions du conseil d'administration
certains dossierers ou pas il n'y a que
le conseil d'administration anticorps
qui peut autoriser le président de
l'association à agir dans un dossier
c'est-à-dire porter plainte faire une
plainte simple si jamais s classé sans
suite faire une plainte avec
constitution de parti civile c'està-dire
aller saisir un juge d'instruction et si
jamais le procureur à l'issue de
l'enquête préliminaire décide lui-même
de saisir un juge d'instruction
l'association peut aussi se constituer
par partie civile de manière très simple
pour participer à l'instruction du
dossier être présente dans l'instruction
ou d'ailleurs il y a des dossiers dans
lesquels on décide d'intervenir au stade
de l'audience devant le tribunal
correctionnel
question expérience de pensée
imaginez-vous vous recevez un dossier
très structuré très fourni très très
bien éteayé sur le président de la
République qu'il est par exemple c'est
une expérience de pensée le président de
la République de l'année prochaine ou
dans 10 ans ou de il y a 15 ans euh euh
vous recevez ça un dossier très bien
ficelé avec des choses bien concordantes
vous vous dites on y va ça va prendre
trop le temps on pourra pas traiter
d'autres affaires ou ou euh on est parti
pour se cramer pour pour aller euh alors
c à 15 ans il y a des chances que ce
soit prescrit donc on pourra pas y aller
euh mais si on a de manière générale une
un dossier contre une personne qui est
extrêmement influente politiquement euh
c'est probablement pas quelque chose
qu'on va prendre en compte dans le sens
où s'il y a bien une association qui a
le courage de s'attaquer à des personnes
politiques puissantes c'est anticorps on
a porter plainte dans énormément de
dossiers qui secouent les personnes les
plus puissantes de la République on peut
parler d'alexie
ca c'est quoi les petits bateaux oui les
petits bateaux ou et des petits bateaux
peut-être qu'il avaient transporté des
substances non aussi MS a été mis en
cause pour trafic de drogue ou en Italie
c'est une des plus connecté avec les
Balcans non je sais je j'ai pas les
détails parce qu'on s'est pas intéressé
au volet euh trafic de drogue euh
présumé euh de MSC mais en revanche
c'est une immense multinationale et
c'est une plus groses boîes de fret ils
étaient peut-être pas au courant qu'il
transportaient des substances je sais
pas ah bah ça on sait pas après euh les
les contrôles sont vraiment perfectibles
hein je suis allé visiter en Italie le
port de Julia Taoro qui est euh qui
essayit de d'améliorer les les contrôles
sur les bateaux bon apparemment il y a
encore beaucoup de choses qui passent
mais en tout cas c'est un c'est un sujet
qu'ils essaient de prendre prendre en
compte notamment parce que oui souvent
dans les dossiers il y a des
interactions entre bah les trafics de
type mafieux en fait que peuvent être
sont souvent les trafics de drogue et
les les les sujets de corruption et pour
revenir pour revenir à à ce qu'on disait
qu'est-ce qu'on disait la la
prescription c'est combien de temps euh
la prescription ben c'est 6 ans
la la seule hypothèse dans laquelle on
peut faire partir le début de la
prescription plus tard c'est quand les
faits sont
dissimulés sauf que bon la la chambre
criminelle de la Cour de cassation a une
interprétation assez laxiste de ce de ce
concept là c'est ce qui ce qui a fait
que l'affaire qui concernait Richard
Ferrand on parlait de personnes
puissantes anticorps à pé plainte contre
Richard Ferran qui à l'époque était
président de l'Assemblée nationale
dans cette affaire là il y a eu un non
lieu parce que la chambre criminelle a
considéré que c'était prescrit ils ont
considéré que c'était prescrit parce que
il y avait il y avait eu une information
sur la situation de Monsieur Ferrand
vis-à-vis de son épouse qui avait si
vous vous souvenez acheté un
immeuble dans le cadre de de la fonction
de Richard Ferrand qui était de de
présider les mutuels de Bretagne et
l'argent venait d'où l'argent venait
d'où l'argent venait des mutuels de
Bretagne qui qui est un organisme de
droit public euh de droit privé pardon
excusez-moi justement j'allais dire ça
c'est un organisme de droit privé mais
quand on préside les Mutuel de Bretagne
on est en charge d'une mission de
service public ce qui fait qu'on est
justiciable des infractions à la
probité et donc bah la chambre criminel
à à sauveré à sauveré Richard Ferrand et
bon on a le droit de critiquer des
décisions de justice je sais on a pas le
droit de dénigrer la justice c'est dans
le code pénal mais on a le droit de
critiquer des décisions de justice pour
le coup celle-ci je je pense qu'on peut
largement la critiquer parce que dans ce
dossier-là il y avait même des
obligations d'information du conseil
d'administration du commissaire au
compte il y a pas eu cette information
considérer que l'information était
publique alors que même une une
information une communication qui était
rendue obligatoire par la loi n'a pas
été effectué c'est quand même assez fou
et et la la chambre criminelle de la
Cour de cassation B c'est le boulot de
la Cour de cassation elle est là pour
dire quel est le droit en France donc ça
veut dire que ce que dit la chambre
criminelle doit être euh mis en œuvre
par toutes les juridictions de France
donc c'est c'est grave
Paul pour pouvoir faire tout ça
un petit peu le le phare la
veille civique civile de des des
affaires de corruption il vous faut un
agrément absolument c'est quoi comme
agrément ça tombe du ciel c'est normal
vous le demandez on vous l'accorde vous
es obligé de pleurer pour l'avir vous
êtes obligé de de faire quoi pour l'
voir vous la retirez récemment vous l'
remis c'est une longue histoire je vais
commencer par le début c'est 2013 en
fait avant 2013 on navait pas besoin
d'agrément on pouvait aller en justice
une association comme la nôtre pouvait
aller en justice demander réparation
pour des faits de corruption et le
caséchan se constituer partie civile ça
dépendait du juge d'accepter cette
constitution partie civile ou pas en
2013 il y a un scandale que tout le
monde a à l'esprit c'est le scandale de
l'affaire kusac et pour promouvoir la
lutte contre la corruption et bien la
loi a créer un mécanisme d'agrément qui
est destiné à faciliter l'action de
l'association comme la nôtre devant le
juge pénal alors pour les jeunes
générations qui connaissent pas Jérôme
Cahusac qui était ministre des du budget
ouis du budget qui était censé regarder
l'évasion fiscale des gens qui avaient
des comptes en Suisse au Luxembourg et
un jour a été incriminé par des
journaliste comme quoi il avait des
comptes en Suisse et il a été juré les
yeux dans les yeux devant l'Assemblée
nationale h non je n'ai pas de compte en
Suisse voilà gen limite il jait sur la
tête de sa mère et la conséquence disons
salutaire de l'affaire Cahusac c'est que
le mécanisme de l'agrément a été créé
qui nous a
permis d'agir en justice de manière très
efficace grâce à cet agrément l'agrément
c'est un acte qui est donné par une
autorité publique le ministre de la
justice c'est un peu problématique parce
qu'on doit demander Élise vient de le
rappeler à des autorités qu'on peut le
cas en mettre en cause de nous accorder
un droit pour les mettre en cause donc
c'est un peu circulaire comme mécanisme
et c'est un mécanisme qui pour cette
raison est criticable parce que on vient
demander à une autorité qu'on peut aller
mettre de en cause devant le juge pénal
de nous donner ce sésame permettant
d'agir contre elle cet agrément il nous
a été donné en 2015 en 2018 en 2021 par
le premier ministre Jean Castex pourquoi
le premier ministre
parce que on était en conflit avec le
garde des sauts de l'époque Monsieur
duup pont moréti qu'on avait mis en
cause devant la Cour de Justice de la
République et Monsieur Dupont Moretti ne
pouvait se prononcer sur une demande
d'agrément relative à une association
qui contesta son action donc c'est le
premier ministre de l'époque Jean Castex
qui s'est prononcé Jean Castex nous a
donné un agrément le 2 avril 2021 qui
était vicié vous comme une pomme qui
contient un verre on voit pas très bien
le petit trou dans lequel le verre est
introduit mais la pomme va finir par
pourrir à la fin c'est sûr c'est ce qui
nous est arrivé monsieur cassec nous a
délivrer un vrai faux agrément ce que
j'appelle l'agrément bien mal écrit
c'estàd qu'il se présente comme un
agrément mais il nous a causé des
désagréments pendant plusieurs années
parce que l'agrément comportait une
motivation qui disait qu' on ne peut pas
être agréé anticorps ne peut pas être
agréé en l'état mais vu nos engagements
l'agrément nous est quand même délivré
donc il y avait en quelque sorte un
effet de ciseau dans l'agrément entre
des motifs qui ne permettait pas qu'on
soit agréé et une décision finale qui
nous a agréé et on a vécu avec cette
poutre pourrie pendant pendant 3 ans on
a fait des actions pendant 3 ans sur ce
fondement tout à fait bancal que le juge
administratif a annulé à juste titre
pour une part juste dit parce qu'il a
dans cet agrément qui nous a été délivré
le 2 avril 2021 il y a ce qu'on appelle
une erreur de droit une contradiction
dans la motivation soit on était agréé
soit on n'était pas agréé mais on
pouvait pas être en même temps si j'ose
dire non agréable et agréable et donc ça
c'est l'agrément du 2 avril 2021 et puis
le dernier agrément qui nous a été donné
c'était il y a peu de temps le 5
septembre 2024 c'est Gabriel Atal juste
avant de quitter Matignon l'heure
d'avant a signé l'agrément sur lequel
maintenant nous pouvons fonder nos
actions devant le juge pénal vous
l'aviez fait condamner
à vous avez quand même chercher un peu
l'agrément l'agrément on a été le
chercher oui avec avec les dents oui
oui on a été le chercher avec les dents
pour la raison que en réalité il s'est
passé quelque chose d'assez
tragique c'est que l'agrément du 12
avril 2021 était signé par Jean Castex
et ce qui aurait dû se passer c'est que
Jean Castex aurait dû défendre becs et
ongles son propre texte c'est quand même
lui le responsable de ce texte il était
plus en fonction ce texte aurait dû être
défendu par sa successeur
madameisabeth borne elle était plus en
fonction ce texte aurait dû être défendu
par le successeur de Madame borne
monsieur Gabriel Attal qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé ni madame born ni monsieur
hatal n'ont sérieusement défendu
l'agrément que Monsieur Castex nous
avait délivré qui était mal écrit et
donc nous avons dû nous faire le travail
de l'administration dire que la
l'agrément de Monsieur Castex était
fondé Infiné c'estàd que nous
remplissions les conditions pour obtenir
l'agrément et et ce qui s'est passé
c'est que Matignon n'a pas sérieusement
défendu l'agrément de Monsieur Castex
Matignon a été silencieux Matignon a
utilisé la procédure de l'agrément pour
la détourner de sa finité pour ne pas
nous accorder d'agrément ce qui s'est
passé votre interprétation ils avaient
peut-être d' ch à fouetté non ce qui
s'est passé je j'imagine que matinon
était avait d'autres préoccupations mais
la procédure de l'agrément a été
utilisée de telle manière que nous ne
l'avions pas nous étions obligés de le
demander de manière successive et nous
n'avions aucune réponse matigon nous a
gosté pendant plusieurs
mois nous avons
demandé d'avoir cet agrément nous avons
demander pourquoi on ne nous répondait
pas et on nous a gsté pendant près d'un
an et demi et donc vous avez fait
comment pour vous
dégoster vous avez envoyé Inès et devant
devant le ministère faire une greffe de
la fin dans une tente accroché dans un
arbre elle s'est enchaîné même pas même
pas alors elle a peut-être fait ça à
notre insu non non je je vous assure que
non pas bon alors on a utilisé
uniquement les voies légales pour
obtenir l'agrément avec beaucoup de
patience mais aussi beaucoup de
tristesse parce que ce que ça a dit de
du fonctionnement de notre
administration et pour le moins on va
dire
déconcertant en réalité l'administration
le gouvernement aurait dû favoriser
notre action il a essayé de la
défavoriser pourquoi je ne sais pas il
faudrait que vous invitiez peut-être
Gabriel
àal votre
interprétation de de ce non favoritisme
de d'agrément c'est quoi c'est parce que
pour parler trivialement et un peu
vulgairement vous êtes un peu trop
fouill merde pour eux euh vous êtes
considéré comme trop tatillon vous êtes
considéré comme étant instrumentalisé
vous êtes considéré comme quoi je ne
sais pas ce qui est certain c'est qu'on
n'est pas instrumentalisé ça je peux
vous le certifier en fait pour pour
expliquer pourquoi est-ce que l'agrond
anticord dérange il faut expliquer à
quoi il sert parce
que en fait c'est c'est c'est quelque
chose de très moderne en fait finalement
par rapport à d'autres pays de l'Union
européenne qui ont pas forcément les
mêmes problèmes qu'en France euh en fait
si cet agrment a été créé c'est parce
qu'on a on a un fonctionnement des
institutions en France qui est un peu
particulier euh déjà on a un procureur
de la République qui n'est pas une
autorité de poursuite indépendante euh
ça c'est l'Union européenne qui nous le
dit euh pourquoi parce que sa carrière
dépend en partie du ministère de la
Justice donc il peut euh être muté à
Mayotte et cetera ou Mayot c'est très
joli ou ne pas être promu d'ailleurs
c'est aussi des questions de
d'autocensure euh parce que bah
forcément si la gestion de carrière et
et au ministère de la Justice voilà ça
peut ça peut embêter et la deuxième
chose c'est que ce procureur il
bénéficie de l'opportunité des
poursuites c'estàdire qu'il a le pouvoir
de classer s suite et ça c'est pas
forcément la même chose dans d'autres
pays de l'Union européenne il y a des
pays qui répondent au système de la
légalité des poursuites un procureur qui
n'est pas parfaitement indépendant qui a
le pouvoir de classer son suite et des
citoyens qui sont complètement démunis
euh parce que même si on a parlé des
chiffres 120 milliards c'est une
évidence que nous sommes tous en tant
que citoyens victimes de la corruption
et ben on ne l' pas au sens procédural
c'estàd queaucun citoyen prenons une
affaire qui est terminé l'affaire Fillon
l'affaire Fillon on parle de
détournement de fonds publics à plus
d'un million d'euros il me semble aucun
citoyen ne peut dire je suis victime
dans l'affaire Fillon puisque cet argent
n'est pas allé dans les services
publicqus dont je n'ai pas pu bénéficier
c'est un discours qui n'est pas possible
devant une juridiction genre si ma femme
accouche sur le parking de
l'hôpital ça peut être la faute de
Fillon non non non les seules
configurations un citoyen peut dire
qu'il est victime c'est quand il a il a
il a un préjudice direct c'estàd
vraiment vous prenez l'histoire de votre
voisin file un pot de vin au maire pour
construire sans respecter les règles
d'urbanisme applica dans la commune là
il a un préjudice direct le le citoyen
sur sur ce préjudice diffus en fait
n'appartient à personne et du coup si
les associations antiorruption se sont
créées si l'agrément a été créé c'est
justement pour que ce préjudice
appartienne à quelqu'un à une
association et que une association
puisse représenter l'ensemble de ses
citoyens en justice en disant bah en
fait on n'est pas d'accord pour que des
des dossiers soient classés sans suite
pour qu'un procureur qui peut-être a
peur que sa carrière soit verrouillée
classe ensuite un dossier même si
vraiment je j'aime pas généraliser et je
je j'iniste sur le fait qu'il y a plein
de procureurs qui sont courageux et que
c'est pas un métier qui est facile à
faire et que d'ailleurs il devrait pas
être dans une tion d'avoir peur pour
leur carrière c'est pas
normal et que
donc cet agrément est un un et un outil
hyper puissant et c'est un outil citoyen
ce qui est assez rare en fait il y a pas
tellement d'outils dans les mains des
citoyens et donc dans n'importe quel
dossier s'il y a une attente à la
probité présumé et que le procureur
décide de classer sans suite pour
diverses raisons peut-être aussi parce
qu'il a pas le temps parce que c'est pas
une priorité dans les politiques pénales
et bien il y a que une association
anti-orruption qui a cet agrément qui
peut contester ce classement sans suite
et en contestant ce classement s suite
en fait on va chercher sur le bureau du
proc qui ne veut pas agir le dossier
saisir un juge d'instruction et apporter
le dossier devant le juge d'instruction
pour lui donner les moyens d'agir parce
qu'un juge d'instruction ne peut pas
s'autoaisir il est saisi par le proc ou
par la victime donc en fait l'action
d'anticorps vise à empêcher l'impunité
d'une certaine classe politique Paul l'
dit tout à l'heure c'est vraiment pas
tout le monde faut arrêter de
généraliser donc évidemment que cette
action là dérange 120 milliards ça fait
quand même un peu de pognon non ah ça
fait un peu de pognon le le PNF le
parquet national financier en récupère
un petit peu moi j'aimerais bien qu'il
soit que leur budget soit calculé sur
les milliards qui font rentrer dans les
fonds publics c'est combien leur budget
ah c'est une col le budget je ne sais
pas je sais combien ils ont rapporté
encore je ne suis plus très sûr moi non
plus mais en tout cas ils sont seulement
dans le rapport annuel ouais mais ils
sont seulement 18 magistrats par exemple
c'est extrêmement peu les lanceurs
d'alertees par exemple Stéphanie gibbaau
qui a permis de récupérer tout un tas de
elle a rien eu elle a rien eu elle est
au RSA la loi sympa avait dit peut-être
que les lanceurs d'alertes on allait
comme faire comme aux États-Unis les
leur donner une petite enveloppe pour
éviter qu'on les
anéantisse vous suivez ça ou pas oui oui
bah c'est en fait il y a eu plusieurs
avancées en France sur les lanceurs
d'alertees
il y a eu la loi Sapin 2 effectivement
il y a eu là le règlement européen ouis
qui est rentré en application en France
via la loi
vaserman un député qui n'a pas été réélu
pour le coup c'est dommage parce que
cette loi est importante et aujourd'hui
il y a toujours pas de rémunération
possible du lanceur d'alerte en France
ça avait été évoqué à un moment on avait
pensé
confier au défenseurs des droits je
crois une une compétence pour aider et
donner des au lanceur d'alerte c'est
jamais passé parce que comme très
souvent il y a cette ce soupçon que les
personnes soient intéressées qu'elle
fassent ça pour l'argent et cette idée
un peu de pureté du lanceur d'alerte qui
finalement est assez violente parce que
les gens très souvent quand ils lancent
l'alerte dans le cadre d'une entreprise
ils finissent tous crucifi bah ils sont
harcelés ils sont mis au placard ils
sont licenciés souvent ils sont
boycottés dans leur milieu professionnel
c'est ça la réalité il y a plein de
choses qui qui découlent de ça il y a
des ils ont ils ont des problèmes de de
famille on a vu des des divorces des
gens qui av des problèmes de santé donc
pour qu'une personne prenne le risque
d'alerter pour dire à toute la société
que là il y a un problème d'intérêt
général là il y a un danger pour la
santé pour l'environnement pour pour
notre société et que ça finisse comme ça
effectivement c'est c'est très compliqué
inè est-ce que vous voulez à compléter
amender ou on part sur un autre sujet
euh non non pas compléter enfin s non
mais simplement sur l'utilité de
l'agrément parce que tout à l'heure vous
disiez pourquoi est-ce que anticorps
dérangé et Elise a hyper bien expliqué
en fait à quoi on servait et ça enfin ça
ça permet aussi d'expliquer les choix
des dossiers en fait anticorps c'est un
peu un instrument qui permet de
contourner les blocages c'est-à-dire que
nous on va pas dans tous les dossiers on
n pas la possibilité d'aller dans tous
les dossiers mais comment on choisit nos
dossiers en fait on va dans les dossiers
qui sont bloqués parce que il y a un
parquet qui a pas envie d'enquêter qui
fait un classement sans suite ou alors
il y a un dossier un parquet qui ouvre
une enquête mais qui la laisse traîner
pendant 2 ans 3 ans 4 ans 5 ans sans
qu'il se passe jamais rien et nous on a
cette possibilité de faire un petit peu
pression sur le ministère public et de
dire attention on va vous prendre le
dossier on le met sur le bureau d'un
juge d'instruction indépendant donc ça
c'est hyper important de le dire enfin
c'est voilà c'est c'est ça en fait la
valeur ajoutée d'anticorps c'est de
faire en sorte que les
dossiers économiqu et financiers qui
concern les infractions à la proprité ne
soi pas enterré et que la justice puisse
être enue dans ces dossiersl et après
pourquoi est-ce que Anticor a eu ses
difficultés lié à son agrément on le
saura jamais mais il y a quelque chose
qu'on peut constater c'est que c'était
juste une période où en anticorps qui
parmi les associations qui disposent de
cet agrément qui permet d'agir en
justice était l'association qui allait
dans le plus d'affaires on est dans plus
de 150 affaires c'est pas le cas des
autres ONG qui font aussi beaucoup de
travail mais qui font beaucoup plus de
plaédoyer ou alors qui sont dans des
dossiers qui concerne plus
l'international et un peu moins
l'exécutif en place par exemple ou voilà
et donc je pense que ça c'est quelque
chose qui nous a potentiellement porté
préjudice Élise vous a hyper bien
expliqué le dossier alexyolaire c'est
vrai que nous en fait on s'est constitué
parti civile dans dossier colaire grâce
à notre agrément et si on avait pas eu
l'agrément dans le dossier colaire il y
aurait eu un classement sans suite et on
en restait là aujourd'hui le secrétaire
général de l'Élysée qui est bien sûr
présumé innocent il est quand même mis
en examen pour pour prise illégale
d'intérêt donc et sans anticorps en fait
il aurait jamais été mis en examen donc
ça c'est quelque chose qui peut-être
peut-être nous a un petit peu causé du
tort forcément parce qu'en fait on est
un petit peu aussi des bah des
empêcheurs d'enterrer les dossiers et
donc il il y a une difficulté
supplémentaire d'abord ça a pas été
précisé je crois que c'est important de
le dire il n a en France que trois
associations agréées trois c'est
vraiment très très peu anticorps
transparencie internationale et Cher pas
et comme vient de le dire Ines CHP de
chez William oui cherp de oui créé par
l'avocat William Bour comme bienent le
dire Ines chaque association a sa
spécificité la nôtre et d'avoir bien
évidemment des activités culturelles
j'espère qu'on on parlera tout à l'heure
mais aussi des activités contentieuses
des activités pénales assez assez
importantes par rapport en tout cas aux
deux autres même si comme vient le dire
Ines on peut pas tout traiter loin sans
faux voilà il y a une difficulté
supplémentaire pour l'agrément que je
souhaite souligner c'est qu'il faut
avoir l'agrément comme l'a dit tout à
l'heure Élise non seulement au jour où
on va devant le juge pénal où on se
constitue parti civil mais l'agrément
doit pour qu'on puisse être indemnisé
doit être euh acquis tout au long de la
procédure pénale qui peut durer
plusieurs années et le fait d'avoir
perdu l'agrément et bien peut faire
tomber nos en tout cas notre
indemnisation et ne nous ouvre plus la
porte du juge pénal euh ce qui a des
conséquences très très néfastes euh pour
les procédures qui sont en cours et puis
au-delà de l'indemnisation euh on s'en
est rendu compte quand on a perdu
l'agrément il y avait une fragilisation
de l'ensemble de nos procédures donc
plus de 150 procédures à l'époque euh
parce que donc on se retrouvait sans
agrément don parfois dans des
instructions qu'on avait mis en
mouvement du coup toute l'instruction
l'information judiciaire était fragilisé
et en fait on avait des personnes qui
étaient mis en examen qui pouvaient
contester la recevabilité de la
procédure entière et faire en sorte que
tout tombe après moi une des
spécificités d'anticorps que j'aime bien
rappeler c'est que nous on est dans les
instructions précisément pour les faire
bouger donc on s'est retrouvé aussi
pendant plus d'un an sans agrément avec
une énorme perte de chance
l'impossibilité de demander des demandes
d'actes l'impossibilité de demander
d'auditionner ou telle personne et en
fait il y a des dossiers dans lesquels
il s'est rien passé moi j'ai vu des
dossiers d'instruction dans lesquels ce
qui a été versé au moment de la perte de
notre agrément c'était bah l'annulation
d' notre agrément et ensuite plus rien
et au moment où on le retrouve et bah on
a on a des des des un invit surination
et des réquisitions au fin de nonlieu
donc en fait voilà c'est c'est juste des
dossiers qui sont restés un petit peu
qui sont un peu morts pendant cette
période en tout cas qui était un peu
dormant pendant toute cette période et
ça ça été une perriode de chance énorme
et après il y a un autre risque c'était
risque de prescription il faut rappeler
que en France si on ne dépose pas enfin
le simple dépôt d'une plainte qui qui
est pour le coup ouverte à tous les
citoyens à la différence de la plinte
avec constition de partie civile elle
n'interrompt pas la prescription
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que nous anticorps on avait encore la
possibilité de déposer des plaintes et
des signalements seulement parfois on
avait des dossiers qui étaient un peu
anciens ou alors on avait déposé des
plaintes depuis longtemps mais le
procureur n'avait jamais ouvert
d'enquête préliminaire et si le
procureur ne fait pas un acte d'enquête
interruptif de la prescription et ben le
dossier il pouvait être prescrit et on
s'est retrouvé avec des dossiers en fait
qui avait vraiment des risques de
prescription hyper importants et parfois
même des prescriptions parce qu'on
pouvait plus interrompre interrompre
cette prescription ça c'était c'était
hyper grave il faut quand même noter
qu'on a et pour des raisons non prévues
sauvé pas mal de dossiers oui oui parce
que quand on a eu l'agrément qui a été
par la suite annulé donc l'agrément de
d'avril 2021 les mois qui ont précédé on
était dans une tempête médiatique assez
importante on était sur une incertitude
très importante sur le fait que cet
agrément nous serait renouvelé ou pas et
euh ça prenait beaucoup de temps et en
fait le cabinet du premier ministre nous
envoyer
des des documents pour dire que
l'agrêment valait encore 3 semaines
valait encore 2 semaines et du coup
avant la date fatidique et dans
l'incertitude de savoir si on allait
récupérer cet agrément en fait on a
demandé à nos avocats de se constituer
particip dans 25 procédures euh et euh
du coup ça veut dire que au au moment de
la constitution de partie civile on
avait un agrément qui était toujours
valable pour le coup on avait le
document la lettre la lettre du Premier
ministre et ça ça a permis de sauver
d'une certaine manière beaucoup de
dossiers parce
que parce que du coup le juge
d'instruction était valablement saisi il
était valablement saisi parce que au
moment de la constition de partie civile
anticorps avait un agrement valable euh
ce qui après on a on a été dans une
situation où on était plus en difficulté
parce que si on avait saisi un juge
d'instruction avec un agrément qui
n'était pas valable rétroactivement là
pour le coup c'est toute l'instruction
qui tombe puisque je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure que le juge d'instruction il
n'est valablement saisi que par le proc
ou par la partie civile si le proc ne
saisit pas et que la partie civile a
saisi sur la base d'un agrément qui
était invalide là on a carrément des
questions de nullité de procédures
entière donc c'était c'était vraiment
très efficace finalement toute toutes c
ce que je considère comme étant une
procédure bon finalement contre anticorp
pour nous retirer cette capacité ou une
lenteur administrative non c'est c'est
impossible par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé avant avant vraiment que la
situation soit dégradée à la direction
des affaires criminelles et des grâces
au cabinet du premier
ministre on a jamais eu une situation
comme ça et même en 2018 quand on a eu
le renouvellement de notre agrément bon
on était quand même un peu surpris parce
qu'on avait déjà fait des actions contre
de personnalités politiques de premier
plan extrêmement puissantees euh
en 2021 on avait anticipé que le
renouvellement allait allait secouer
vraiment parce que quand on met en cause
le secrétaire général de l'Élysée qui
est le bras droit du président de la
République quand on met en cause le
président de l'Assemblée nationale on on
s'attend bien à ce que il y ait des des
pressions sur la justice pour que ces
procédures ne puissent pas aboutir et
anticorps est est un outil qui sert
justement à ce que ces procédures
aboutissent on nous on veut pas
forcément obtenir des condamnations dire
si les gens sont pas coupables ils sont
pas coupables c'est merveilleux euh mais
si les infractions ont été commises nous
on veut que les élus soient jugés qui
répondent à la justice quand on répond à
la justice à travers elle on répond aux
citoyens et c'est normal les
responsables politiques doivent rendre
des comptes euh au aux citoyens donc
nous
notre notre notre volonté c'est c'est ça
en fait que on espérant que Ben du fait
que la justice agisse on espère dans des
des raisonnable qu'elle punisse parfois
sévèrement parce que il serait tant
qu'elle le fasse euh le phénomène de
corruption euh
diminue on va revenir sur le phénomène
de corruption qui ne diminue pas et et
peut-être que c'est à cause du fait que
certains fondamentaux économiques de
notre
société sont en train de calancher de
trébucher donc c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'on voit les phénomènes de corruption
réémerger comme ça d'une façon beaucoup
plus dans la lumière juste une question
comme ça vous qui suivez des des détails
de procédure de corruption en général le
pognon il est utilisé à faire quoi
est-ce que ça finance des trains de vie
extraordinaires par exemple en ce moment
il y a en Espagne le problème d'un
narcotrafiquant qui graissaent la patte
de certains policiers donc ça leur
permettait d'avoir des appartements de
luxe des voitures de luxe et tout de
luxe où est-ce que ça bénéficie au
financement de parti politique au
financement de groupes terroristes au
financement de tout un tas de de de
bêtises comme ça des
anecdotes on a beaucoup de dossiers où
finalement ce qui est financé là dos
passés on ne rentre pas dans le détail
pour le coup anecdotique euh
effectivement les les les personnes
visées sont sont présumé innocentes bon
on a eu les sites de rencontres euh là
la drogue la chat drogue bon j'ai
j'allais dire c'est anecdotique en fait
ça me fait pas rire parce que même si on
parle de 10000 € même si on parle de
20000 € ben en fait c'est c'est un poste
dans une administration m'attends à des
montages financiers passons par gersy
guerneuset certaines îes dans les
Caraïbes
avec remonté je pense qu'une partie de
cet argent part dans les paradis fiscaux
et c'est là qu'on a un lien entre la
corruption et l'évasion fiscale bien
évidemment il y a des sociétés qui sont
accusées d'avoir obtenu illégalement des
marchés publics et qui sont des sociétés
qui par ailleur ne payent pas d'impôts
en France B voilà remonter est assez
facile avoir et je pense
que partiellement cet argent est utilisé
effectivement pour financer les
campagnes
électorales vous avez des des infos un
peu plus à nous communiquer ah benah on
a dit on a dit présomption d'innocence
ouis non tu as quelque chose à en terme
de volume ça représenterait quel volume
de financement des centaines de milliers
d'euros des centaines de millions d'os
absolument pas le dire les chiffres
qu'on a c'est les chiffres de la
corruption dont on a parlé il y a des il
y a un chiffrage aussi de ce que
représente l'évasion fis fiscal par an
et ce chiffrage c'est c'est dommage mais
il est un peu il remonte un petit peu
maintenant c'est le le syndicat
solidaire finance publiqu qui a chiffré
entre 80 et 100 milliards d'euros par an
uniquement en France le coût de
l'évasion fiscale moins que la
corruption moins que la corruption moins
que la corruption oui si vous mettez
évasion fiscale et corruption ensemble
on arrive à 200 milliards mais comme on
vient de dire c'est possible que ce soit
en parti le même argent et et et la
question du financement des partis
politiques la question du financement
des campagnes électorales est tellement
importante euh que oui ça c'est pas
étonnant et d'ailleurs ce que ça veut
dire si c'est le cas ça veut dire que
des campagnes électorales sont financées
sur fond public en fait sur avec de
l'argent public détourné c'est
gravissime on fait tout le est-ce qu'il
y a des acteurs qui se sont spécialisé
sur le blanchiment de corruption ou de
blanchiment de fraude fiscale ça vous
est jamais arrivé aux oreilles h
non
Paul pourquoi avoir été président
d'anticorps pourquoi être président de
bon d'abord Élise m'a demandé si je vous
accepté de participer au conseil
d'administration ce que j'ai volontiers
accepté parce que Anticor traversait une
zone de turbulence et que j'ai pensé qu'
était de mon devoir de
citoyen de renforcer c'est autant que je
pouvais un contre-pouvoir citoyen il se
trouve que j'ai quelques compétences en
matière de justice administrative et que
les turbulences qu'anticorps traversai
étai précisément du à des difficultés
purement administratives et donc j'étais
assez bien outillé pour pouvoir aider
anticorps à ce moment-là sur ces
questions-l et donc moi et nous je pense
je peux parler pour tout le monde ici
nous défendons la séparation des
pouvoirs nous défendons les
contre-pouvoirs contrepouvoir
institutionnel un exécutif un parlement
de justice mais aussi contrepouvoir
citoyen comme le nôtre notre
contrepouvoir citoyen était en grande
difficulté pour les raisons qu'on vient
d'indiquer qui sont tout à fait
indépendants de notre volonté on était
strictement pour rien on est
irréprochable sur ce point donc
anticorps était en difficulté comme
contrepouvoir et j'ai pensé que mes
compéten de juriste mon expérience de
juriste spécialisé en droit
administratif pouvait aider a surmonter
ses difficultés et c'est ce qui s'est
passé heureusement l'histoire n'est pas
encore terminée nous avons encore un peu
de travail sur ce point- là mais voilà
la raison de mon engagement en faveur de
l'action de la société civile à travers
anticorps pour la lutte en faveur
d'thque publ inè quand vous passez sur
les plateaux télé 2 minutes 30 ou 5
minutes 30 vite vite vite il y a une
incompréhension des journalistes où ils
comprennent ils commencent à saisir que
il faut prendre du temps que c'est c'est
des dossiers longs que ça a été masqué
ou que il y a eu des phénomènes pour
masquer où ils sont bonjour Ines comment
ça va alors ça se passe bien chez
anticors euh je pense que ça dépend mais
non il y a une il y a une compréhension
quand même du sujet après ça nécessite
d'avoir un peu envie de garder la parole
garder le micro pour expliquer ce que
c'est ouais un petit peu pour expliquer
ce que c'est un détournement de F public
par exemple pour expliquer ce que c'est
le procès du RN pourquoi par exemple des
assistants parlementaires ne peuvent pas
être financés euh sur euh enfin avec les
fonds du Parlement européen pour faire
autre chose que ce pourquoi ils sont
employer c'est-à-dire participer au bon
fonctionnement du Parlement européen et
ne peuvent pas par exemple travailler
pour un parti politique ça c'est un
détourement de fond public et ça c'est
hyper important de prendre le temps non
seulement d'aller dans les procès pour
le dire mais aussi euh d'aller sur les
plateaux pour le dire euh on peut parler
si on parle un petit peu de la
couverture médiatique des affaires
d'infraction à la probité juste une
parenthèse il y a que le RN qui se fait
attraper parce qu'il y a que le RN qui a
mis les doigts dans le pot de confiture
ou c'est tous les partis politiques en
ce qui concerne en ce qui concerne les
les détournements de fond public et les
questions de d'assistants parlementaires
non ça concerne pas que le RN on a vu
que ça avait concerné le modem ça peut
concerner en fait plein d'autres gens
même en dehors du Parlement européen il
y avait aussi des questions avec le
Parlement en France bon bah on a compris
enfin l'affaire Fillon PEL Fillon mais
donc voilà qui ont employé également sa
femme et là pour le coup elle
travailleit même pas pour son parti en
fait elle travaillait à priori pas du
tout bon c'est c'est une question il y a
eu aujourd'hui par exemple on a délibéré
dans une une affaire un peu locale qui
concerne calvire dans le 69 et cocher
qui est un un maire en exercice qui a
été condamné aujourd'hui pour
détournement de fond public et son
épouse aussi pour r les complicités de
détournement de fond public en fait
parce que elle a bah plus de 700000 € en
fait parce qu'en fait elle a été en
employé pendant des années mais en fait
cétait assez rigolo parce qu'elle était
employée pour en tant qu'assistante
parlementaire a priori le tribunal a
retenu que elle ne travaillait pas elle
était payée plus que le député en fait
et elle était payée plus que tous les
autres collaborateurs parlementaires
donc non bien sûr c'est pas uniquement
le RN après il va faire appel ouais bien
sûr ils vont faire appel donc ils sont
encore présumés innocents moi ce que je
vous dis c'est ce qu' a retenu le
tribunal correctionnel c'est pas moi qui
le dit mais le tribunal correctionnel a
dit qu'elle travaillait pas bon et ils
ont peut-être pas pu faire la preuve bah
c'est ça qui est rigolo parce que
justement ils ont apporté donc ils nous
disent 300 pièces mais moi j'étais à
l'audience pendant 2 jours et en fait il
y a rien dans ces pièces dans ces pièces
il y avait quelques plusieurs dizaines
de mails qu'elle aurait fait en je sais
pas 10 ans d'exercice en ça avait voilà
ça avit ça avait assez peu de Ch qu'elle
a travaillé plus que pénéop Fillon parce
que je sais pas peut-être un petit peu
plus pon il avit l'histoire des
enveloppes 25 enveloppes par semaine je
sais plus c'est ça bon madame cocher
elle expliquait qu'elle a porté le
courrier le lundi matin et qu'elle
l'ouvrait voilà est-ce que c'est
suffisant pour avir avoir sur fond
public un salaire qui est plus important
qu'un salaire de député moi voilà c'est
une question qui m'interroge après donc
en effet c'est pas uniquement le
rassemblement national mais il y a quand
même des spécificités avec la comprz
vous comprenez pourquoi je pose la
question bah parce que c'est quelque
chose qui est énormément dit et c'est
pour ça que je voudrais aussi c'est une
critique en fait mais c'est en fait
c'est la critique très très classique de
toutes les personnes qui sont et tous
les partis qui sont mis en cause dans
les affaires d'infraction à la proiété
qui disent ah mais on tape toujours sur
les mêmes on tape toujours sur nous B
non non non en fait l'argument je suis
désolé de vous
couperutoriser oui allez-y là l'argument
c'est bon vous voyez il y a le
rassemblement national ou le Front
national appelez ça comme vous voulez
qui monte qui monte qui monte et on est
en train de faire un procès politique
pour neutraliser le Front national mais
pas du tout alors c'est caricature oui
mais al moi je suis très contente de
pouvoir répondre à cette question parce
que en fait pas du tout le le l'enquête
a pas été ouverte par un parque français
elle a été ouverte par l'OLAF euh
ensuite euh ensuite elle a elle a été
transmise à des juges d'instruction on a
eu 10 ans
d'instruction ça ça sort aujourd'hui
donc c'est-à-dire que d là on a on a le
le procès on a eu le procès du RN là à
un moment où le RN considère que ils
sont très très puissants dans notre pays
sauf que cette instruction elle dure
depuis 10 ans et cette instruction elle
aurait pas duré aussi longtemps si par
exemple Marine Le Pen avait pas refusé
de se présenter devant le juge
d'instruction cette instruction elle
aurait pas duré aussi longtemps non plus
s'il y avait pas eu un nombre de de
mesure de de procédurees dilatoire qui
avait pas été mise en mouvement par
Marine Le Pen donc je ça un peu
singulier c'est légal oui alors c'est
légal sauf le fait de refuser de se
présenter devant le juge d'instruction
pour le coup c'est quand même à la
frontière de la légalité en en utilisant
son son immunité parlementaire à ce
moment-l B c'est voilà c'est c'est on va
dire que c'est à la frontière mais ça
fait pas le jeu de la justice et la
célérité de la justice de toute façon je
pense qu'il y aurait jamais de bons
moments si on écoute les personnes qui
sont mises en cause pour être mise en
cause il préférait que ça n'arrive
jamais on nous dit que c'est pas le bon
moment non plus dans l'affaire on nous
disait que c'était pas le bon moment
sauf que c'était juste une révélation de
la presse alors là qu'est-ce que c'est
le bon moment les élections
présidentielles c'est pas non plus
demain ENF je veux dire c'est c'est
quand même un peu je trouve que c'est un
peu compliqué de nous dire là ça
intervient trop tard bah ça intervient
trop tard mais il aurait fallu peut-être
que l'instruction puisse aller plus vite
si on l'avait laissé aller plus vite
c'est toujours trop tard ou trop tôt et
la réponse c'est toujours ça c'est
toujours la part des élus ils disent
toujours c'est partisan c'est parce que
je suis élu parce que je suis dans tel
parti politique que vous m'attaquez ils
nous le disent aussi à nous à anticorps
parce que nous pour le coup on a fait
des actions contre des des responsables
politiques de bord différents c'est pas
c'est pas ça l'enjeu pour nous et vous
avz fait les
écologiste on on fait pas excusez-moi on
fait pas tel ou tel groupe on fait pas
ce qui est certain c'est que il n'y a
jamais de bons moment pour être parti à
un procès pénal c'est toujours une étape
extrêmement douloureuse extrêmement
pénible c'est vrai euh ce qui est
certain aussi c'est que la justice n'a
pas d'agenda c'est évident c'est ce que
vient de dire euh Iness Bernard dans
dans l'affaire du RN ou dans l'affaire
du modem ou dans l'affaire Cochet ou
dans l'affaire Fillon il y avait pas
d'agenda il n'y a pas d'agenda
judiciaire en disant ah euh il peut y
avoir une élection présidentielle parce
que le président Macron va démissionner
en décembre donc on va euh faire un
procès le le vin c'est ça je ne sais pas
je suis pas dans les petits papiers donc
il n'y a pas d'agenda de la justice ça
n'existe pas ce sont des fantasmes
absolus il y a une procédure pénale qui
peut être plus ou moins longue c'est
comme un chewing-gum quand on le
mastique et ben on peut faire une bulle
avec et bien les prévenus peuvent
mastiquer leur schwinggum pénal et faire
durer une procédure qui pourrait être
raccourcie autrement et dans dans ces
cas là quand ils font quand il délay il
délay il délay il ralentissent c'est
leur droit absolu d'accord mais la
justice derrière quand a elle met les
mains dans le camboui elle se rend bien
compte qu'ils ont fait traîner traîner
traînerelle est un peu plus Durou mais
non mais en fait précisément la justice
dans ces cas-là elle va requérir ou
après elle va elle va prononcer une
peine avec exécution provisoire et c'est
aussi pour ça que l'exécution provisoire
existe et moi j'aimerais bien le
rappeler parce que pour le rassemblement
national nous dit voilà on a requéri
contre Marine Le Pen Paron contre Marine
Le Pen une peine
d'inéligibilité avec avec exécution
provisoire bah l'exécution provisoire
elle
est on la sollicite justement parce que
la procédure a été extrêmement longue et
qu'on nous dit maintenant il va falloir
que la peine soit appliquée un jour il
va falloir que si la personne est
reconnue coupable sa peine s'applique et
que la personne ne s'engage pas dans des
recours qui sont parfois des recours
dilatoires on sait que Marine Le Pen
elle risque de saisir la Cour d'appel si
elle est innocente bah très bien et ben
si elle est innocente elle sera à ce
moment-là innocenté innocenté elle aura
elle aura eu en attendant cette peine
d'inéligibilité avec exécution
provisoire ça ne la concerne pas elle
seulement ça concerne toute personne qui
bénéficie d'une exécution enfin qui est
sous le coup d'une exécution provisoire
donc il n'y a pas de raison de la
particulariser parce
que particulariser telle personne parce
qu'elle pourrait être candidate à telle
fonction parce qu'elle pourrait animer
une émission avec 1,2 million d'abonnés
sur Youtube nous sommes toutes et tous
des justiciables ordinaires il n'y a pas
encore heureux on fait on fait tout
pourou et puis ouais justement en fait
nous anticorps on est présent dans plein
d'affaires et donc la peine
d'inéligibilité hein qui est prévue qui
est pas toute nouvelle hein qui qui qui
existe depuis 94 et en fait qui a été
rendue obligatoire par la loi sapan
c'est-à-dire que désormais cette peine
elle doit s'appliquer en matière
d'infraction à la probité alors pourquoi
en matière d'infraction à la probité
parce que c'est quand même des
infractions particulières c'est parce
qu'on considère que ces infractions
elles sont tellement tellement graves
que euh les parlementaires ont voulu
mettre à l'écart du jeu politique
certaines personnes parce qu'en fait
elles porterit atteinte à la au bon
fonctionnement démocratique donc c'est
déjà important de le dire ensuite donc
ces peines normalement elle s'applique
elle s'applique obligatoirement sauf
qu'à ce que le juge rende une décision
spécialement motivée pour expliquer
pourquoi il ne l'appliquerait pas donc
et ensuite en ce qui donc nous en fait
dans tous les procès dans lesquels on se
rend on voit lorsque les personnes sont
reconnues coupables et condamnées elles
sont condamnées à des peines
d'inéligibilité c'est normal c'est
automatique et en ce qui concerne
l'exécution provisoire moi j'aimerais
dire que je le vois extrêmement souvent
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure de la
faire cocher pour lequel le délibéré a
été rendu aujourd'hui le maire de calvir
il a été condamné a une peine
d'inéligibilité de 5 ans avec exécution
provisoire demain il ne sera plus maire
de sa commune et en fait c'est ça aussi
qui est important de dire c'est que
cette peine d'inéligibilité avec
exécution provisoire elle s'applique aux
élus locaux et quand elle s'applique aux
élus locaux les élus locaux ils doivent
quitter leur poste donc c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement violent et il est
c'est une question d'égalité devant la
loi qu'elle soit aussi appliquée aux
autres élus et aux autres aux autres
personnalités politiques c'est
just chauffeur et tout c'est terminé il
se plainent beaucoup moi je voudrais
quand même dire que bon Marine Le Pen
elle parle de mort politique d'autres
personnes font à peu près le même
constat tu dis que c'est violent c'est
quand même moins violent que la prison
et on est en train de parler d'une
infraction pénale qui est punie au terme
du code pénal une peine de 10 ans d'
prisonnement bien sûr
euh et moi j'aimerais bien qu'on qu'on
réfléchisse à comment la justice réprime
ce type d'infraction pénale parce que je
crois qu'il y a une certaine tolérance
de la justice et il faut que les les
juges de ce pays arrêtent d'être
tolérant avec les élus cert
l'inégibilité c'est bien c'est une
espèce de mort politique c'est vrai
c'est une manière de mettre à l'écart de
la vie publique des responsables
politiques qui ont
démérité mais il se trouve que la
corruption ne baisse pas en France donc
peut-être qu'à un moment il faut aussi
envoyer le message queil y a pas de même
pas ce type d'impunité pour les élus et
que si un élu seront coupable de prise
illégale d'intérêt de corruption de dé
en fond public en fait il va passer
quelques années derrière les barreaux et
peut-être que là il y aura une vraie BAE
du phénomène en mode VIP en mode
bracelet électronique comment ça se
passe parce que là je vois quelqu'un qui
a Brasset électronique il fait les
inaugurations de machin il signe des
bouquins non le Pr électronique ça
marche pas les les les gens quand on
croise les gens un peu partout quand on
va dans les festival les réunions ils me
disent ouais d'accord super il y a pas
d'élu qui vont en prison ils ont raison
quand il y a un élu qui va en prison
pritour oui quand balc va en prison on
en parle tous les jours sur bfn c'est la
première fois pour des raisons de santé
c'est la première fois qu'on parle des
conditions de détenenstion en France sur
BFM son épouse qui est tous les jours
sur sur BFM qui fait une pression
monumentale sur l'opinion publicque pas
tous les jours et surtout euh balc a
été sorti de prison pour cause de
raisons de santé je vous assure queil y
a plein de gens malades en prison et là
encore on est sur une forme d'inégalité
on est toujours sur une forme
d'inégalité si on faisait sortir de
prison toutes les personnes qui ont le
type d'affection médicale qu'à monsieur
balcani ben en fait il y aurait plus de
problème de surpopulation
cartiéral vous connaissez les prisons un
petit peu très bien oui j'étais enfin
trs bien pa pourquoi tu connais les
prisons j' été visiteur de prison tu
étais visiteur vous étiez visiteur de
prison oui pourquoi euh parce que j'ai
rencontré quelqu'un qui s'était beaucoup
intéressé à la condition carcérale et
j'ai voulu voir enfin cette personne m'a
disons euh à élevé mon attention sur
cette condition carcérale et j'ai voulu
apporter mon mon grain de voilà ma ma
graine citoyenne à l'amélioration de la
condition carcérale et donc j'ai été
visiteur de prison pendant quelques mois
années voilà et quelle prison la maison
d'arrêt de freine peu importe ouais
furouis jamais non non non non non je
freine ouaou la santé non non j'ai été
invité en prison la maison d'arrê de
freine voilà pendant une et freine c'est
bien il y a des trous dans les murs il
faut 12 degr la prison c'est pas bien
comment ça se passe il y a pas la
personnel c'est pas enfin c'est c'est
personnel c'est pas lié à à notre
engagement associatif mais je considère
que la prison doit être évitée au au
maximum faut pas faire de
bêtises ben oui déjà il faut pas faire
de bêtises et puis il faut surtout
éviter l'enfermement qui en réalité
n'est pas la la bonne mesure pour
prévenir la la récidive ça c'est mon
opinion personnelle qui est documenté
vous vous vous documentez auprès des
pays nordiques qui ferment leur prison
pour faire des Airbnb oui
notamment je suis pas trop sûr que je
sais pas si on sera sur la même longueur
d'onde parce que c'est pas l'objet de
notre association mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est de vous connaître oui
euh donc à titre
personnel je suis contre je suis pour la
limitation à des cas très très restreint
de l'enfermement je considè alors on
fait quoi on fait des stages de
réhabilitation on fait des coups de
bâton on fait quoi on trouve d'autres
modalités de
punitionou des modalité plus plus
pédagogique présenter comme ça c'est
caricatural mais c'est fait exprès et
ben ça marche bien parce que c'est
caricatural mais de fait les
statistiques montrent que la prison
c'est l'école de la récidive ça ne peut
pas être autrement parce que quand on
est enfermé on passe des mois à disons
qui sont gelés dans une
vie c'est vrai qu'on a sans doute pas
envie de retourner en prison mais ce
sont des mois qui sont complètement
perdu il y a pas de formation
professionnelle il y a des activités en
prison et on peut faire des études en
prison il y a des activités il y a des
des des des personnes de l'ex pe faire
du
carte il peut y avoir des activités
effectivement mais c'est tout à fait
anecdotique l'enfermement c'est une
punition et il est parfois nécessaire
d'y avoir recours mais mais c'est une
punition qui est
très infantilisante pour la personne qui
qui l' subit c'estàdire que cette
personne ne ne peut pas être amélioré
par un passage en prison effectivement
c'est une punition ça d'accord mais il
faudrait qu'il a aussi un versant
éducation et ce versant éducation il est
totalement absent du milieu
pénitenciaire pour des raisons tout
simplement matérielles aujourd'hui
l'état des prisons en France est
dramatique
h nous sommes condamnés de manière
récurrente par la Cour européne des
droits de l'homme il n'y a pas une 11ce
d'amélioration donc la politique qui
consiste à enfermer davantage en réalité
créer un cercle vicieux puisque cet
enfermement disons continu et bien ne
permet pas aux personnes qui sont
informés de d'éviter de revenir dans
cette situation voilà mesdames vous avez
visité des prisons vous aussi non moi
une seule fois je suis allé à à la santé
seis en tant qu'avocate euh sa santé
toujours aour shit ah non pas quand je
suis passé mais c'était peut-être pas
bon a toujours autant de stupéfiant dans
les prisons françaises je sais pas j'en
ai jamais consommé je je sais pas je sa
mê pas reconnaîre l'UR non non je dois
dire que quand la porte de la prison se
referme en tout cas c'est le sentiment
que j'ai eu même si on sait qu'on est
avocat qu'on ressort évidemment quand on
veut il y a un sentiment
de d'angoisse Imagineer le personnel
pénitencier assez important oui imagine
qu'on l'a pas tous les jours quand on
travaille tous les jours oui mais il y a
des phénomènes de corruption dans les
prisons ah bah des matons qui passent
des petits trucs contre des petits trucs
des non ça existe ça en France je crois
qu'on a pas eu de cas particulier on
est'est pas en mesure le documenter très
bonne réponse Paul mais on finalement on
a beaucoup parlé de l'argent qui qui
manque partout et et bon la réponse à ça
ça a été beaucoup des politiques de de
rigueur budgétaire ça a été beaucoup des
des coupes budgétaires
on est aussi là pour dire que en fait
cet argent qui manque c'est l'argent de
la corruption qu'à cause de la
corruption bah tout le monde paye
beaucoup plus d'impôts déjà on on pense
au au porte-monnaie mais non mais en
France çaê un sacré niveau de corruption
parce que tous les contribuables payent
des impôts pour compenser les coûts
directs et indirects de la corruption et
vous disiez où où vont ces ces 120
milliards euh ça fait 15 ans que je suis
anticorps j'ai on est beaucoup dans les
dossiers on est beaucoup dans le dans le
tous les jours
j'ai pas pris le temps de de faire un
rapport sur la question mais ce que je
constate moi c'est
que le jeu pour pas mal quelques-unes
grandes entreprises c'est d'obtenir de
l'argent public et ça ça se fait via
l'obtention des marchés
publics ça se fait des subventions des
subventions publiques effectivement
contre aux entreprises et et aux
associations aussi d'ailleurs parce que
via les associations aussi il y a des
Dét de fond
public donc ça se fait de de de cette
maère là et il y a un montant d'aide
colossal qui a attribué ça par l'État
sans aucune contrepartie j'ai pas les
chiffres je suis désolé euh sans aucune
c'est quoi colossal c'est 50 € 100 € non
on parle de milliards de milliards on
parle d'ancien franc non non non non on
parle de
Milard non non plus
mais la il y a eu le le plan de de
relance on s'est toujours dit en on
allait regarder la question je ça fait
mal au cœur de voir que notre pays est
commencé à être gangrainé un peu à ga
est-ce que ça fait mal au cœur de voir
des services publics sur le carreau
des des infirmières à 1500 balles des
pompiers par reconnus comme profession
dangereuse est-ce que ça fait mal au
cœur de voir des des des personnes âgées
passer 14 16h 24h sur un brancard par 8
degrés avec des patients qui se font
agressés dans tous les sens des patients
des soignants se faisant agresser dans
tous les sens des enfants malgériel a de
l'enfance on peut on peut parler de tous
ces caslà en fait les les services
publics sont un moyen de donner à la
population un minimum de sécurité
d'accès à l'éducation aux soins à la
justice évidemment que ce manque d'accès
là crée des préjudices et créer de la
souffrance et moi le la raison de mon
engagement anticorps c'est ça bien sûr
c'est c'est l'injustice que la que la
corruption provoque euh dans la
société en fait plus une société
bénéficie de service public plus plus on
lisse le niveau de de de vie la qualité
de vie de tout le monde plus on a une
société qui est heureuse et a priori en
tout cas si on lit la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme le job d'un
gouvernement c'est de travailler au au
bonheur au bonheur des citoyens on a
aujourd'hui situation économique
terrible je Seris pas vous dire
exactement quels sont les liens mais on
a 300 plans de licenciement économique
qui arrivent on a des des nouvelles qui
sont qui sont désastreuses moi par
exemple sur le le sujet de l'accès à
l'eau dont on parlait en arrivant on a
eu scandale sur scandale sur l'eau en
bouteuille c'estàd qu'il y a des
partical de plastique qu'on ingère quand
on boit de l'eau en bouteuille au-delà
du coup pour l'environnement évidemment
on acheté de l'eau en bouteuille mais en
plus là on a un scandale il y a
apparemment 9,6 millions de Français qui
consomment de l'eau qui est polluée au
titrium au tritium titrium je crois ti
TR déchet nucléaire
quoi résidu déch nuéire c'est dans les
dores t'emb pas non mais c'est fou quand
même c'est trop on va changer la N c'est
fou et moi j'aimerais c'est des c'est
des sujets sur
lesquels on pourrait se mobiliser pour
travailler parce que normalement il y a
il y a des chaînes de responsabilité il
y a des organismes publics qui sont en
charge mais c'est l pour les pauvres
quand on est riche on boit de l'eau en
bouteille en verre oui mais quand on va
dans certains supermarchés de plus en
plus en France dans dans beaucoup de
pays étrangers effectivement il y a une
rangée immense d'eau en bouteuille y
compris d'eau en verre et ça ça me ça me
fait de la peine ça me choque et puis en
plus maintenant on a la TV à 20 % sur
l'eau en bouteille c'est bien et je ce
que je voulais dire par là c'est que il
y a une chaîne de décision il y a une
chaîne de contrôle c'est notre c'est
notre boulot de de vérifier si les
contrôles ont été faits s'il y a des
conflits d'intérêt quelque part qui font
que les contrôles ont pas été fait s'il
y a des détournements qui font que les
agents n'ont pas les moyens de faire ce
type de contrôle tout ça c'est hyper
hyper important c'est un travail que
peut faire s'il y a des gens qui ont des
informations là-dessus euh je rappelle
que anticorp peut être saisi et ça c'est
par exemple un sujet de santé publique
qui est hyper important et moi je serais
vraiment ravie que des lanceurs d'alerte
viennent nous voir sur ce sujet
d'ailleurs tu peux aussi rappelez qu'on
a un système hyper sécurisé pour lancer
l'alerte à anticorps donc s'il y a des
informations qui sont hyper sensibles si
les personnes ont peur pour leur travail
et cetera on peut mettre en place oui un
bouton sécurisé sur notre site qui
permet de de lancer une alerte qui sera
chiffrée donc avec toutes les alors
c'est chiffré avec quoi c'est
ça a été vérifié on verra ça un peuard
moi je suis pas une informaticienne
global global c'est ce qu'utilise le le
site sources
sû qui a un conglomérat de journaliste
qui a ouis i c'est ça oui pas que il il
y a pas mal de médias qui son avant de
redonner la parole à inè tout de suite
après vous avez fini oui oui j'ai fini
je mets je mets je lançais un appel sur
la question de l'au non mais on va on va
revenir sur la question de l'eau et puis
le cas de conscience on fait tous
ensemble une expérience de pensée
imaginez-vous dans un beau pays avec des
sources thermales qui descendent dans
les montagnes et qui est filtré par les
petits cailloux de la montagne pour
donner ce bon petit goût d'eau
minérale bon on se retrouve avec des
montagnes polluées des napes fratiques
pollué donc on se retrouve avec de l'eau
en bouteille bon
pollué on vous
saisit mais le fait de révéler ça vous
menacez x millions d'impôts x millions
de TV a x millions de de de de
travailleurs qui vont se retrouver avec
une boîte qui va fermer donc
imaginez-vous dans ce beau pays
imaginaire dans un état imaginaire avec
un un pouvoir politique imaginaire le
pouvoir politique qui est saisi par
l'industriel l'industriel dit écoute si
on continue ces normes là on met la clé
sous la porte ta TVA tu va t'asseoir
dessus ton emploi tu vas t'asseoir
dessus tu comprends donc en gros tu
fermes les yeux on continue un peu le
business on va attendre que les
particules de caca ou de plastique qui
flottent dans la NA fratique elle se
tasse un petit peu ou la pollution
avec que ce soit l'agriculture où je
j'en passe les meilleurs dans ce beau
pays est-ce que vous si vous recevez
l'alerte qui peut menacer x milliards de
TVA x millions d'emplois vous avez un
cas de conscience où vous y
allez je je vais me
permettre oui je tu as est-ce que vous
allez demander la permission à vos deux
collègues bien sûr merci et ell me l'ont
donné c'est vrai ça oui bon ça va c'est
bon c'est
ok on n' pas de conscience à anticorps
parce que c'est ce n'est pas nous qui
jugeons ce n'est pas nous
qui décidons
infin nous nous recevons des alertes ça
a été dit et le processus a été indiqué
tout à l'heure par Élise après un filtre
puisque vous parler d'eau un filtre pour
euh des des altes quel bout en train
oui je suis davantage en dehors de ce
plateau euh encore
euh après un filtre de de des des
alertes qui nous sont données nous
décidons ou pas de saisir le juge pénal
mais ce n'est pas nous qui directement
ou indirectement mettant en cause des
intérêts particuliers ou des intérêts
publics voilà nous saisissons le juge
pénal comme nous l'avons dit et soit le
juge pénal décide qu'il n'y a pas lieu
d'instruire et class l'affaire soit le
juge pénal l'instruit et saisit un juge
d'instruction et vous êtes juriste
j'essaye bon là je vous pose la question
d'une façon plus directe vous savez que
si vous appelez le juge h avec les
pièces que vous avez reçu oui et votre
expérience oui et vous savez
pertinemment que le juge il va voir
qu'il y a un problème donc est-ce que
vous êtes attirer quand même l'attention
du juge oui malgré le fait que ça menace
x milliards x milliards de TVA x
millions d'emplois x millions de de
choses vous y allez quand même ou pas si
nous estimons nous sommes 21 membres du
conseil d'administration si une majorité
de 11 membres du Conseil
d'Administration décide d' aller mais
bien évidemment on se pose aucune
question particulière mais il y a des
débats qui se produisent en amont et si
nous décidons qu'il qu'il faut saisir le
juge pénal nousous nous le faisons sans
sans sans État d'â
particulier sur qu'gy pour sauver oui en
fait il y a la question des conséquences
sur les personnes morales donc sur les
entreprises j'ai l'impression que c'est
là-dessus que vous voulez aller ah bah
les entreprises elles vont être
condamnées à à payer des amendes qui
sont énormes et ensuite ell elles se
retrouveront elles se retrouveront à
devoir licencier comme le disait ellise
maintenant le parquet a la possibilité
de conclure des conventions judiciaires
d'intérêt public c'est-à-dire c'est de
la justice négociée et l'entreprise mise
en cause va négocier avec le parquet le
montant d'une amende qu'on considère
comme étant d'intérêt public pour ne pas
avoir de déclaration de culpabilité donc
ça c'est quelque chose nous Anticor on
est très très opposé mais pour le coup
c'est quelque chose c'est une c'est une
possibilité qui est hyper favorable aux
associations on y opposé pourquoi parce
qu'en fait on considère que la justice
pénale elle doit être rendue dans des
procès publics c'est pas des cabinets
d'avocats qui doivent conclure avec le
PNF ou alors avec parfois des parquets
de région qui sont be beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus bah fragile avec moins de
moyens encore des des conventions pour
dire que il y aura finalement pas de
reconnaissance de culpabilité ensuite
une des peines enfin une des
conséquences de l'inscrption au
casadiier judiciaire des entreprises
d'un certain nombre de condamnations
pour des infractions c'est
l'impossibilité de concourir au marché
public donc en fait si ces entreprises
qui respectent pas la loi qui commettent
des infractions à la probité elles ont
pas de peine il y a jamais
d'impossibilité de concourir au marché
public donc en fait elles vont conclure
ces jeip sur GIP sur ses Gy sur ses Gy
ses Gy convention judiciaire d'intért
publique sur convention judiciaire
d'intér publique c'est hyper loin à dire
sur convention judiciaire d'Inti est s
on a le temps OK et ben je voilà et donc
ça c'est mon premier mon premier élément
de raisonnement donc nous on est voilà
on est profondément contre la ségip
enfin contre la convention judiciaire
d'intérêt public aussi parce qu'on
considère que c'est une inégalité devant
la loi que quand c'est des citoyens qui
commettent des infractions en fait ils
ont des peines et ils ont des amendes et
il y a des reconnaissances de
culpabilité donc en fait il y a pas de
raison que est cette imp é pour les
personnes morales et ensuite la dernière
chose que j'aimerais dire c'est en
revanche nous on est très très attaché à
ce que les personnes physiques qui sont
les dirigeants de ces entreprises elles
rendre des comptes devant la justice
parce que vous faites état des
conséquences sur les personnes moral et
des amendes mirobblance qui vont être
payé mais ça c'est si la personne morale
est mise en cause mais il y a aussi la
personne physique qui peut être mise en
cause quit du dirigeant le dirigeant lui
doit être envoyé devant la justice parce
qu'en fait il y a aucune infraction à la
probité qui peut être commise tout seul
par une entreprise une entreprise ne va
pas ne pas respecter un marché enfin ne
va pas corrompre un décideur tout seul
ça n'existe pas il y a des personnes qui
sont au commande et ces personnes là
c'est elles aussi qui commettent ces
infractions là et elle elle doit
répondre des faits devant la justice
elles doivent avoir des condamnations à
des peines des amendes et ça ça remettra
jamais en question la viabilité de
l'entreprise derrière donc c'est hyper
important alors deux choses alors c
fameux responsable n'est pas coupable
c'est
ça oui mais enfin comment ça
oui c'était pas tout à fait le même
contexte pasable m deuxè chose vous m'z
fait perdre mon fil deuxème chose sur
sur les condamnations oui
euh quand on dit la France a été
condamnée parce que son système carcéral
est défectueux traitement inhumain sur
surcharge de population carcérale
conditions de vie dégradante il gens
pass des pass des d'illeurs je crois
qu'on a été condamné par qui d'autre qui
nous avait dit c'était
limite non la cour EUR droit de l'homme
voilà quand c'est une
administration il y a forcément des gens
à la tête de l'administration h il y a
forcément des gens à la tête du système
carcéral ou à la tête du système
pourquoi il démissionnent pas ces
gens-là parce qu'ils sont aussi
responsables c'est comment moi Mo je
vois l'administration comme une
entreprise l'administration est jamais
coupable a toujours un minist qui jamais
coupable le fonctionnaire il est jamais
coupable celui tête de service il est
jamais coupable bon il aura peut-être un
petit
blâ une administration c'est pas une
entreprise un ministre peut être mis en
cause devant la Cour réisttion a des
gens qui gistration ilre beaucoup
d'ailleurs qui g des y a beaucoup
d'administrations il n'y a que ça des
administrations des administrations
nationales des administrations locales
et cha AD tion à un ou une responsable
et des chefs de service donc
effectivement il y a un nombre de
responsables tout à fait conséquent et
ces responsabl et ben ont des
responsabilités qu'il et ell assument et
pas seulement dans les mots comme le
font certains et certaines mais aussi
concrètement il y a il est possible de
mettre en cause la responsabilité de de
ce responsable public sauf que ces
responsables public par rapport aux
dirigeants entreprise qu'on vient de
mentionner ils agissent non pas en leur
nom personnel mais au nom de la personne
publique à laquelle ils appartiennent
donc donc il faut distinguer ce qu'on
appelle et j'espère qu'il y a beaucoup
d'étudiants et d'étudiantes en droit qui
nous regardent la faute de service qui
concerne la responsabilité de
l'administration c'estàdire une
administration X ou Y c'est facile et la
faute personnelle qui concerne un agent
particulier Monsieur ou Madame X ou Y et
heureusement dans la plupart des erreurs
commises par l'administration qui concne
extérieur aux atteintes à la probité
c'est la responsabilité du service en
général de de telle collectivité de tel
commune de tel département qui c'est
quand même nébuleux ça non c'est pas du
tout nébuleux c'est extrêmement clair et
et et extrêmement clair et bien euh
borné depuis depuis plusieurs dizaines
d'années mais parce que j'ai
l'impression que ce que vous mettez en
cause par exemple quand vous parlez des
prisons en fait c'est le manque de
moyens le manque de moyens peut pas le
le Lefin on peut pas dire que c'est
ouais on peut pas le reprocher à une
personne à une personne de
l'administration par cont on peut
reprocher par exemple un comment ça
s'appelle un BAFA voyez un BAFA un gamin
qui s'occupe d'autres gamins en vacances
là payer misère bon quand on leur
apprend dans les textes voilà vous avez
le droit d'encadrer h enfants bon bah
s'il se retrouve avec 14 gamins il y en
a un qui meurt noyé et ainsi de suite ah
bah le BAFA il aurait pas dû prendre la
colonie de vacances le directeur de de
la colonie de vacances bah il en prend
plein son grade le chef de de de la
conolie de vacances il en prend pas son
grade aussi je suis d'accord mais
pourquoi donc celui qui travaille dans
les prisons il voit des conditions
inumaines d'incarcération fa bonitionne
le retrait ok pourquoi il y a pas ça en
mais si si il y a ça euh par exemple les
étudiants en droit euh connaissent pour
la plupart d'entre eux une décision du
Conseil d'État où il y avait un
militaire qui Fa les bonnettes
intelligentes qui faisait un un un tir
d'armes avec des balles réelles et donc
malheureusement un de ses subordonnés a
été tué bien ce militaire a commis alors
ce qu'on appelle une faute personnelle
il en a payé ben le prix à la fois sur
le plan administratif et sur le plan
pénal voilà donc ça il y a aucune
difficulté mais en fait ce qu'il faut
voir c'est qu'en réalité et on en
revient au début de notre entretien
c'est qu'en réalité il y a très peu
heureusement très peu infraction
notamment à la probité qui sont commises
par les agents publics il y en a c'est
très très résiduel c'est extrêmement
résiduel c'est pourquoi on ne peut pas
feuilletonner sur ce sujet-là c'est
pourquoi 90 95 % peut-être même
davantage des agents publics n'ont
jamais et ne commettront jamais
d'infraction à la probité et donc ne
commettront ni faute de service ni faute
personnelle et il faut se réjouir de ça
maintenant au-delà c'est vrai qu'il y a
des politiques publiques ça a été dit
des politiques publiques qui conduisent
à une dégradation des services publicqus
c'est le cas pour les prisons voilà
c'est acté là aussi par des instances
international mais ça ça dépend pas des
des agents publics ça dépend pas du
maire de Paris ça dépend pas de du
président ou de la Présidente de la
Région Île-de-France c'est une politique
publique
Inès à force de gérer ce type de dossier
qui touche notre pays nos services
publics nos administrés nos citoyens nos
profs nos hôpitaux
est-ce que ça vous met pas à vous tous
d'ailleurs c'est valable la question
est-ce que ça vous met pas un coup au
moral de voir tout ça de de voir que on
est censé être la France on est censé
être une puissance d'envergure mondiale
et et est-ce que le fait maintenant
d'avoir les mains dans le gou de rond
dans dans le cambouille de voir qu'en
fait c'était peut-être qu'une belle
histoire que la France éétait pas un
pays corrompu est-ce que c'était
peut-être une façon aussi de protéger
tout ça oui quand on entend un un avocat
vos confrères qui encore avocat qui va
peut-être être démis de ses fonctions
ran Branco vous connaissez h quand il
dit ils sont la
corruption ça vous fait penser à quoi je
vais permetre de répondre Juan banco
bénéficie d'une liberté d'expression
égale à la nôtre donc il peut dire tout
ce qu'il veut et et et nous
aussi le phénomène corruptif il est il
est très limité je voudrais insister sur
ce point milliard ça fait quand même un
paquet de pognon hein c'est beaucoup
d'argent c'est énormément d'argent et 1
€ ce serait trop mais c'est pas
énormément de personnes voilà c'est ça
alors si c'est pas énormément de
personnes ça fait milliard dans beaucoup
de poches ou oui je crains que je crains
que oui quand je suis venue en 2021 je
vous disais que sur les dossiers de
corruption qu'on étudie c'est quand même
assez régulier qu'on arrive sur des
marchés public dont l'enjeu financier
est entre 20 et 30 millions d'euros donc
oui 120 milliards ça a l'air énorme mais
la commande publique ça représente des
chiffres des chiffres très importants
oui euh c'est vrai après il y a aussi
une corruption un peu de bas étage qui
est peut-être un peu plus répandu et là
là il y a c'est quoi une corruption de
bah je veux dire plutôt de la corruption
quotidienne c'est-à-dire des maires qui
vont être bah un petit resto pe
bouteille qui vont boî de CD non mais en
fait c'est des c'est des Parc des
Princes ouais benah en fait parfois
c'est vrai qu'on on on peut être amené à
sourire euh à anticorps quand on voit
des dossiers qui sont euh d'ampleur mais
pourtant des élus se sont laissés
corrompre pour quasiment rien moi je
repense à un dossier qui a été jugé au
début de l'année devant la 32e chambre
correctionnelle du TJ de Paris et en
fait il y avait euh plusieurs peut-être
une petite dizaines d'élus
d'île-de-fance qui étaient jugé pour
cette laissée corrompre par la même
société c'était une société du bâtiment
à qui ils accordaient moins d'une
dizaine je pense que c'est plutôt 5 à
peu près élu à qui ils accordaient des
marchés publics et en fait il leur
accorde des dé marchés public contre
quoi contre un weekend en Europe avec
leurs femmes contre le nouvel iPhone
contre un super resto étoilé c'était
ridicule et en fait pourtant les
conséquences de ces faitsl mais elles
sont tellement importantes pour en fait
elles sont importantes parce qu'elles
des conséquences démocratiques énormes
c'està-dire que les gens quand ils
voient que leur mère est complètement
corrompu estce qu'ils ont encore envie
d'aller voter bah j'en doute et puis
ensite ensuite les conséquences
économiques enfin y a des entreprises
qui sont des entreprises qui sont
capables de répondre à ces marchés
publics qui peuvent répondre aux
conditions des marchés publics et en
fait qui mériterait de se voir attribuer
ces marchés publics donc c'est une
question de justice mais c'est aussi une
question d'efficacité question même un
peu capitaliste en fait que ces
entreprises là si elles avaient obtenu
les marchés elles les auraient largement
mieux exécuté que l'entreprise qui en
fait finalement a payé un nouvel iPhone
au maire et qui est en fait parfaitement
incapable de respecter le marché public
qui l' payé sans la v d'ailleurs je sais
ouais peut-être mais ça donc donc voilà
après la question sur est-ce que on est
déprimé moi personnelle je suis
absolument pas déprimé j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on soit déprimé chez
anticorps parce que je vois qu'on est
des personnes qui sont extrêmement
engagées et travailler au quotidien avec
des gens qui sont engagés qui ont envie
de faire bouger les choses et qui le
font en fait dans les fait moi je je
trouve qu'on a bah qu'on qu'on fait un
peu bouger les lignes et anticorps est
une association qui a la capacité de
faire bouger les lignes et c'est aussi
pour ça qu'elle a été menacée et ben ça
c'est extrêmement motivant et
franchement il y a rien de plus
déprimant que l'inertie il y a rien de
plus déprimant que de rester dans son
marasme à constater que la société va
mal et a rien faire nous on agit au
quotidien donc en fait bah on est on
peut pas on peut pas être être être
déprimé de ça après ça nous empêche pas
parfois d'avoir des dossiers qui nous
tiennent à cœur et de voir que les
conséquences de la corruption c'est
aussi des conséquences
humaines souvent vous me parliez tout à
l'heure de la compréhension des médias
du phénomène de corruption euh moi j'ai
l'impression que souvent quand on parle
d'infraction à la probité aux
journalistes ils ont un peu envie de
conclure en disant bon il y a pas mort
d'homme mais en fait finalement parfois
si parfois il y a mort d'homme parfois
il y a mort de femmes et parfois il y a
même mort d'enfants nous anticorps on
s'est impliqué très récemment dans un
dossier qui concernait les crèches et là
c'est aussi en lien avec quoi c'est
aussi en lien avec l'administration et
avec ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
sur le enfin finalement le manque de
moyens c'est-à-dire qu'on a une société
dans laquelle le le l'État c'est et les
collectivités se sont désinvestis de la
gestion des crèches et donc elles ont
favorisé des systèmes de privatisation
avec des entreprises privées qui se sont
un petit peu engoufré dans la dans la
brèche de la gestion des crèches parce
que c'était en fait c'était oui c'était
très profitable en tout cas ça ça
potentiellement ça rapportait beaucoup
d'argent et les crèches pour viux aussi
ça marche aussi oui bah c'est la même
chose enfin la même chose oui mais en
tout cas c'est un autre problème pas
même taille de couche et en tout cas on
s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait une
société qui gérait ses crèches et qui en
fait les géit extrêmement mal et faisait
en sorte d'obtenir de l'état le plus de
subventions possible elle falsifiait des
documents pour obtenir enfin elle
faisait des faux travaux donc elle
utilisait des sociétés qui étaient des
sociétés qui étaient des coquilles vides
total pour faire des faux devis de
travaux qui étaient en fait pas exécutés
et donc en fait les crèches étaient dans
des super mauvaises étapes parce qu'ell
étaient jamais rénové mais par ailleurs
on touchait des subvention pour rénover
ses travaux on on falsifiait enfin on
mentait sur sur le nombre d'enfants
enfant accueilliis on augmenté les
heures de présence des enfants pour
obtenir toujours toujours plus de
subventions donc ça nous on considère
que c'est potentiellement un
détournement de fond public et en fait
c'est quoi les conséquences de ces
infractions là c'est des enfants qui
sont accueillis dans des crèches et qui
sont en fait extrêmement mal accueillis
qui sont mal traités au quotidien par
des personnels de crèche qui ont des des
des qualités de de travail qui ont des
emplois qui sont extrêmement précaires
qui sont mal payés qui sont souspayé et
qui ont des conditions de travail qui
sont difficiles et qui font ressentir
cette difficulté dans leur conditions de
travail sur l'accueil des enfants qui
sont des personnes qui sont extrêmement
fragiles et en fait on l'a vu dans cette
affaire là la la société en cause elle
avait été dans une affaire où un bébé
avait été en fait enfin é avait été
retrouvé mort donc on se retrouve en
fait avec des infractions à la probité
qui on en fait des conséquences sur les
hum vous expliquez journalistes il
percutent un peu ou pas du tout ça
dépend oui parfois oui parfois non
parfois ce qui les enfin parfois ça les
intéresse Mo mais en tout cas c'est
important enfin pour moi c'est c'est
très très important de le dire et on le
voit il y a vraiment des affaires où il
y a des conséquences humaines qui sont
réelles je crois que je pense que c'est
difficile pour la presse de de passer du
fait divers à l'analyse globale de la
situation et souvent nous on est on est
très sollicité sur des affaires et on a
plus de mal à parler de notre plaidoyer
on a un plaiddoyer sur notre site
internet on dit ce qu'il faut changer
euh c'est quoi l'adresse du site
internet c'est
www.anticorp.org euh et donc on a not
plaidoyer sur notre site Internet et on
explique que ce qui selon nous il
faudrait changer dans le dans le système
français dans les institutions pour
pouvoir se battre plus efficacement
contre la corruption ça en fait on a du
mal à en parler dans les médias et très
souvent ben on y va on a 30 secondes 2
minutes et c'est souvent pour parler
d'un dossier parce que les dossiers
intéressent les médias et et un peu
moins le le sujet de Fond un peu moins
le le fait de prendre de la hauteur et
dire en fait c'est un sujet de société
fondamental et en plus on dit 120
milliards d'euros ben en fait ça devrait
être une priorité pour n'importe quel
gouvernement et euh
au lieu de ça on a toujours pas toujours
pas de plan pluriannuel de lutte contre
la corruption ce qui est complètement
fou
normalement c'est tous les 3 ans c'est
ça le plan oui mais en tout cas c'était
ce qui était annoncé par l'Agence
Française antiorruption qui est censé
publier ce plan qui contient des grandes
directions pour la lutte contre la
corruption dans d'utres pays oui alors
vous vous peut-être vous me faites signe
que c'est un petit peu du du pipo mais
sauf que le fait que le violon oua que
le fait pardon j'ai pas reconnu le MIM
mais que le fait le fait qu' pardon non
mais le fait qu'il soit que ce plan là
il soit même pas publié en fait ça
montre l'absence de volonté totale enfin
l'absence de volonté politique totale de
lutter contre la corruption dans plus d'
dans les impr ouais c'est peut-être ça
et j'en veux un deuxième exemple plus de
papier non mais c'est la la question é
en vacances cétait vendredi soir non
mais c'est la question des moyens pour
la justice économique et financière dans
notre pays ouais alors c'est très
Paul si vous m'autorisez juste une
seconde mais sur cette question moyen
ouis on dit toujours il y a un problème
de moyen de moyen de moyen après il y a
les tracteurs qui disent mais ces moyens
sont utilisés n'importe comment mais il
y a quand même des moyens mais on se
pose la
question le budget de la
justice c'est un budget du tiermonde
d'un état du tiermonde c'est c'est
est-ce que c'est pas je je me fais
l'avocat du diable est-ce que c'est pas
fait à
dessin d'avoir tellement de petits
budgets sur la justice les prisons la
chasse antiorruption être obligé de
laisser ça une assaut avec cert des gens
très motivés qui bossent comme des
guudins à s'occuper de 150 dossiers
alors qu'ils sont que cinq et c'est les
incorruptibles c'est vous mais est-ce
qu'on est en France puissance nucléaire
au Conseil des nations- Unies et j'en
passer des meilleurs le fait qu'on soit
obligé nous chez nous Serview de
recevoir une association antiorps qui se
bat qui se bat comme des petits pirates
pour sauver les bébés foc sauf que là ça
fait quand même ça fait je suis désolé
de dire ça mais pour la France ça fait
pas un peu pitié qu'on ait un budget de
la justice aussi pourri et qu'on soit
obligé d'utiliser des associations pour
aller faire la
chasse je vais répondre brièvement mais
je voulais aussi répondre à la question
d'avant italien toi non oui
oui c'est une question de politique
publique voilà ce sont les priorité de
nos gouvernants du Parlement le les
gouvernement Parlement sont élus sur des
programmes voilà et donc il y a des
priorités et dans ces priorités il n'y a
jamais je parle sous le
contrôle de mes voisine il n'y a jamais
la la lutte contre la corruption c'est
c'est jamais une priorité
euh je bon et voilà les politiques
publiques peuvent conduire à à des voilà
des jeux de vases communicant tels que
vous les décrivez de quoi le financement
de campagne ainsi de suite des services
publics qui sont appauvris et des
entreprises privées qui sont
florissantes parce qu'elles bénéficient
soit de déduction fiscale soit de
subvention instrumentalisation du droit
non non c'est pas de le droit est fait
pour être utiliser c'est un outil mais
le secret des
affaires alors là j'ai l'impression de
passer le grand oral pour devenir avocat
je serai des affaires voilà peut-être
qui avocate est-ce que je peux répondre
à la question d'avant sur notre
dépression éventuelle
ah nous sommes anticorps antiorps not
symbo c'est le médicament nous sommes
indéprimables parce que c'est vrai parce
que nous prenons cette petite pilule
bleu ah oui cette petite pilile bleue
tous les jours femm et homme et cette
petite pilile bleue elle repose sur ce
qu'a dit tout à l'heure Élise la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyens qui dit que la lutte contre la
corruption correspond au bonheur de tous
et et de toutes voilà manque de PE c'est
pas bon en fait on invite les gens qui
sont un peu déprimés à venir anticorps
voilà alors je voudrais préciser donc
notre combat nous donne de l'énergie et
cette énergie elle est multipliée par le
fait que je voudrais insister sur ce
point avant qu'il soit trop tard il est
déjà trop tard non un petit mot nos
actions ne sont pas seulement
judiciaires nous avons des événements
culturels extraordinairement festifs et
joyeux je donne deux exemples samedi
dernier à Paris il y avait un festival
du cinéma contre la corruption nous
avons vu des films très sympathique
suivi de conférences très sympathiques
sur le thème de l'éthique publique en
janvier nous avons la remise de prix
éthique qui récompense des personnes ou
des organisations qui ont œuvré en
faveur de l'éthique publique et cette
cérémonie elle est présidée elle est
dirigée par un comédien de de renom
c'est une cérémonie extrêmement festive
c'est qui le comédien on pe Gad mal je
sais pas si c'est la deuxième fois qui
nous fait le plaisir de venir et il a
été invité plusieurs fois chez
chez nous
Ferrari on fait un petit peu de teasing
c'est possible de pas donner son nom
maintenant voilà donc nous avons des
événements extrêmement festifs
extrêmement éducatifs ludiqu pour
atteindre notre ObjC social qui est la
lutte en faveur de l'éthique publique
donc nous ne pouvons pas être déprimés
Paul je peux me faire l'avocat du diable
c'est vous qui posez les questions et
qui avez la réponse à vos propre
question vous concernant ça c'est pas
que vous me décrivez vos événements
culturels animés par un comédien de
renom oui moi je vais résumer ça plus
plus simple c'est encore une éè carmè de
gauchiste qui font des remis des remises
de prix pour se flatter Lego comme quoi
ils se battent fort fort fort fort fort
et derrière ça continue de brasser des
millions est-ce que votre stratégie h
c'est pas un peu le gentil pot de terre
gentil contre le paquebo de fer en ACI
titane forgé et en même temps il y a
plein d'élus qui ont été condamnés grâce
à anticorps il y a plein de dossiers qui
ont abouti grâce à anticorps et en même
temps le secrétaire général de l'Élysée
est mis en examen pour priser lesquales
d'intérêt alors qu'il y avait eu un
classement s suite et alors même que le
Président de la République s'est
prononcé dans ce dossier pour dire qu'il
y avait rien dans l'instruction ce qui
est d'ailleurs un problème en terme de
séparation des pouvoirs et en même temps
on a retrouvé notre agrément le dernier
acte signé par Gabriel fait pour adhérer
dans votre site internet ben on clique
sur adhérer c'est direct ouais il pas
tous en même temps Paul Paul alors déjà
je vrais juste dire on l'a pas indiqué
que nous n'avons pas de financement
public nous sommes financés uniquement
par les dons de personnes privées et par
nos adhésions nous sommes absolument
indépendant et indépendante c'est du
type des impôts des entreis pour celles
et ceux qui en payent c'est 35 €
l'adhésion et pour celles et ceux qui
n'ont moins de 26 ans qui sont
demandeurs au demand de de emplois c'est
12 € pour l'année il y a combien
d'adhérents il y a 7000 adhérents à peu
près ouis h h il en faudrait 70000 ou
700000 ou 700ou 700000 70000 d'ici la
fin du mois ce serait vraiment bien non
mais il faut quand même que tout le
monde garde en tête qu'on fait des
choses difficiles on s'attaque à des
personnages qui sont qui sont puissants
on s'attaque à des systèmes qui sont
extrêmement puissants aussi et mine de
rien quand l'un de nous se présente dans
une salle d'audience B on préfère
pouvoir dire queil y a 70000 personnes
derrière nous euh
que 7000 même si c'est déjà super et on
aimerait énormément pouvoir dire que il
y en a 700000 parce que c'est pas un
combat qui est censé être clivant vous
demandez à n'importe quel homme
politique il va pas vous dire qu'il
adore la corruption bien évidemment que
non et puis anticorps c'est aussi une
association citoyenne dans le sens où
quand on rentre à anticorps c'est aussi
pour comprendre ces phénomènes là et on
travaille beaucoup en ce moment sur des
outils de compréhension parce que moi il
y a un discours que j'entends souvent
dans la presse aussi qui m'énerve à
chaque fois qu'il il y a un procès on
dit ah c'est compliqué alors en fait
c'est pas c'est pas si compliqué quand
on va dans des festivals des réunions
des événnement et et qu'on présente les
infractions à la probité qu'on les
explique on va prendre 1 heure et dem et
généralement après on fait un quiz et je
peux vous assurer qu'à partir de 7 h
questions tout le monde a bon c'est dire
que tout le monde a compris tout le
monde arrive à
reconnaître ce que c'est que la
corruption enfin par rapport aux autres
infractions et euh oui on est en train
de de former si si si les habitants de
ce pays le le veulent bien 66 millions
de procureurs pourquoi pas il ne faut
pas s'arrêter au fait que des médias
disent qu'un sujet est complexe de
procureur ou de
juge non cétait par rapport à
déclaration de d'Emmanuel Macron qui
disait ah les Français c'est 66 millions
de
procureurs nous forcément on n'est pas
du tout procureur mais on sent un peu
concerné par le fait que B en fait c'est
pas si difficile de comprendre les
infractions à la probité et que les
citoyens si S intéressent seront
talentueux pour les pour les reconnaître
euh par exemple bah vous avez une
personne qui est un élu un fonctionnaire
ou une personne plus largement en charge
d'une mission de service public si elle
prend de l'argent pour faire quelque
chose ou ne pas faire quelque chose on
est dans un cas de corruption euh si
elle prend cet argent je dis argent mais
tout avantage quel qu'il soit euh non
pas pour faire quelque chose elle-même
mais pour utiliser son influence pour
qu'une autre personne fasse quelque
chose on ne fasse pas quelque chose on
est devant une situation de trafic
d'influence si cette même personne élue
fonctionnaire chargé de mission de
service publi prend une décision
publique alors qu'elle a un intérêt
personnel à ce que cette décision soit
prise dans un sens ou dans un autre et
bien c'est l'infraction de prise
illégale d'intérêt si cette même
personne attribue un marché public sans
respecter les règles de mise en
concurrence on est dans une situation de
favoritisme et ça marche à l'échelle
européenne ça laéchelle européne c'est
pas forcément le même droit qui est
applicable donc la première question
qu'on se pose quand on est juriste c'est
quel est le droit applicable à cette
situation là mais un cas de figure je
dois je passe les contrats par SMS
comment ça se
passe faut il faudrait vraiment me
laisser le temps d'étudier le dossier
avant de poser une question comme ça
mais si on prend le procès des des
assistants parlementaires que soit RN ou
modem et ils sont tous présumés
innocents encore une fois on est sur sur
des faits qui auraient été commis niveau
des instances Bruxelles et cetera
potentiellement en France là le lien de
rattachement c'est que l'infraction
pénal aurait été commis même
partiellement sur le territoire
français même que la personne poursivi
et nationalité française ça marche aussi
il y a différents liens de rattachement
qui font que un droit est applicable ou
pas on s posé d'ailleurs la question
dans le fameux catar gate parce que vous
parliez de de valise de billets en
direction Bruxelles mais il se trouve
qu'on a trouvé des valises de billets à
Bruxelles en direction de de de je ne
sais où ce qui a été un dans des placard
c'était dans un placard il y avait pas
il y avait pas une une charmante dame
qui est ancienne présentatrice de télé
qui s'est fait attraper avec les poches
pleines de billet non ah moi je parlais
de la vice-présidente du Parlement
européen ah je crois que c'est elle non
Eva k elle était pas ancien sperine ah
ça je j'ai pas regarder son CV ah oui
ouais ok elle était en tout cas en
charge d'une
responsabilité très importante oh
c'était son beaupère ou son copain qui
avait le cach c'était pas
je vous jure monsieur c'est pas mon cach
et bon dans cette manière de de
simplifier les choses à la télé de dire
que c'est toujours compliqué bah
finalement on c'est comme si on faisait
barrage à la compréhension c'est ça et
cette compréhension elle est pas si
compliquée moi je essayé de vous
expliquer rapidement quelles sont les
les infractions à la probité je peux pas
vous faire de quiz en ligne mais euh ben
anticorp par exemple on fait on fait des
ateliers dans les groupes locaux on fait
des trucs symp et vraiment je vous dis
c'est pas si compliqué et les gens
comprennent je vais poser une question à
Paul Paul en terme de peine en terme de
de de quand on les attrape h on voit
qu'il recommence ou que ça continue et
que ça augmente est-ce que vous avez vu
très récemment en Chine le ministre de
la Défense qui s'est fait attraper
ah non non vous avez pas vu est-ce qu'il
faut faire un peu le système asiatique
c'est-à-dire corruption il y a le peine
de mort pas du tout
non je vais je ne répondrai pas à cette
question pourquoi c'est trop
expéditif c'est pas pédagogique
pédagogue non la question elle elle est
elle est trop elle est trop simpliste
voilà je peux pas je peux pas répondre à
cette question elle est elle est
caricaturale c'est fait exprès ça vous
permet d'ouvrir une porte et ben je
je d'abord il y a plus de peine de mort
elle est elle est abolie en France et
puis chaque personne a la possibilité de
réparer l'erreur qu'elle a commise une
faculté de rédemption qui est inhérente
à chacun et chacune d'entre nous donc
rien n'est irréédiable si quelqu'un a
commis un acte contraire à la probité à
telle époque ça veut pas dire que dans
20 dans 30 ans ça il recommencera ou
elle recommencera
voilà et dans le monde la peine de mort
mal à cet effet et bien de d'acter voilà
une peine qui euh est décisive avec le
risque d'erreur qu'elle comporte par
ailleurs donc
elle ne peut pas être envisagé en tout
cas dans le domaine de la probité quoi
qu'il en soit et même au-delà puisque on
est contente de de vous avoir comme
juriste sur notre plateau c'est bien inè
oui alors peine de mort ou pas peine de
mort non non pas peine de mort non non
je suis absolument contre la peine de
mort le bagne bâon la plume non non mais
en fait je vais voilà votre question bon
la peine de mort c'est un petit peu
voilà c'est c'est c'est pour nous faire
réagir bien sûr tout le monde sur ce
plateau est contre la peine de mort ENF
il y a même pas de sujet là-dessus après
il y a peut-être je pense que ce que
vous voulez peut-être sous-entendre
c'est que les peines sont pas assez
dissuasive donc les peines sont pas
assez dissuasives alors ça c'est une
réalité pourquoi les infractions à
laprité elles sont punis potentiellement
de peines qui sont importantes Elise l'a
dit tout à l'heure le détournement ne
font plus c'est 10 ans d'emprisonnement
la corruption c'est 10 ans
d'emprisonnement on est à la frontière
du crime en revanche ces peines elles ne
sont jamais appliquées donc ça c'est une
question après qu'on soit pour ou contre
la prison on peut se poser la question
de d'infractions qui sont punissables de
peine d'emprisonnement ferme importance
et de peines qui ne sont finalement
jamais appliqué première chose deuxième
chose il y a à mon sens et j'en ai parlé
tout à l'heure la peine d'inéligibilité
qui existe justement parce qu'elle est
extrêmement dissuasive pour des élus qui
on envie de continuer à exister dans la
vie publique donc ça ça enfin ça c'est
c'est extrêmement important à mon sens
c'est dissuasif donc c'est important que
cette peine soit aussi appliquée et
ensuite je pense que malheureusement
l'absence de caractère dissuasif il est
aussi extrêmement lié non seulement à au
faible montant des condamnations mais
aussi au fait que ces affaires là elles
mettent des années et des années à
aboutir parce qu'à mon sens c'est le
plus gros problème c'est même pas
tellement que les personnes soient
faiblement condamnées quand elles sont
reconnu coupable c'est qu'une une
affaire va mettre 10 ans 15 ans et
parfois même plus à aboutir ça c'est pas
normal du tout parce que pendant ce
temps-là en fait l'eau a coulé sous les
ponts les personnes vont continué à être
élu les personnes vont continué à être
au Parlement à être dans leur dans leur
municipalité et ça c'est pas normal du
tout ce qu'il faudrait c'est une justice
qui soit quand même plus rapide et pour
ça ce qu'il faut c'est des moyens parce
que ce qui rend pas dissuasif la justice
en France c'est qu'on sait que quelqu'un
peut déposer plainte ou un signalement
contre vous même qu'une instruction peut
être ouverte contre vous et à la limite
vous pouvez être mis en examen mais il y
a rien de mieux pour enterer un dossier
aujourd'hui en France que d'ouvrir une
instruction parce que le juge il ouvre
une instruction puis ensuite il le met
sous une pile de plein d'autres dossiers
d'instruction qu'il a sur son bureau
parce qu'en fait il a beaucoup trop de
dossiers à gérer par rapport à ses
capacités et tout à l'heure vous nous
interrogiez sur est-ce que c'est pas un
peu déprimant enfin pas déprimant mais
est-ce que c'est pas un peu triste la
situation en
France voilà mais ben moi j'aimerais il
y a quand même une chose que je trouve
triste je suis extrêmement optimiste
parce que je travaille avec des
personnes qui sont engagé mais il y a
une chose qui est triste c'est la
situation de la justice parce que nous à
anticorps on va dans plein d'affaires on
constitue parti civil on rencontre des
parquettiers et des juges d'instruction
et nous très souvent ce qu'on nous dit
c'est ah mais j'ai pas d'enquêteur mais
est-ce que vous pourriez m'apporter une
preuve est-ce que ça vous avez la
possibilité vous d'enquêter là-dessus
mais non en fait Anticor ne dispose pas
de la force publique Anticor ne peut pas
faire une perquisition Anticor ne peut
pas convoquer tel ou tel chef
d'entreprise pour qu'il soit reçu par un
juge c'est le juge qui peut faire ça et
c'est ses enquêteurs sauf que les les
magistrat aujourd'hui en France en
matière économique et financière ils ont
plus d'enquêteurs parce qu'ils ont plus
de moyens et ça oui je trouve ça
extrêmement triste et vraiment je le
regrette tous les jours et je dirais
même al je dis à notre sens c'est
peut-être le plus gros obstacle qu'on
rencontre à anticorps aujourd'hui c'est
ça c'est pas c'est même pas l'absence
d'indépendance du parquet dont on vous a
parlé tout à l'heure qu'on regrette
aussi tous les jours c'est l'absence de
moyens c'est le fait que les enquêtes
elles durent que les instructions elles
durent et qu'elles aboutissent pas c'est
qu'on a des dossiers dans lesquel il y a
des dossiers qui sont des dossiers
énormes des dossiers hyper importants
qui qui impliquent d'énormes société
voilà et qui et on a des juges
d'instruction qui nous disent ordonnance
de non lieu parce que anticorps n'a pas
apporté la preuve des malversations mais
en fait on est où c'est pas à Anticor
d'apporter la preuve quand on est
juginstruction c'est aux enquêteurs
d'apporter la preuve et c'est au juge de
le faire sauf qu'aujourd'hui avec la
situation de l'absence de moyens on se
retrouve à reprocher à une association
qui reçoit pas de subvention qu'à cinq
salariés et qui est financé uniquement
par les dons de ne pas avoir réussi à
apporter la preuve de l'
personnelle d'un dirigeant d'une énorme
entreprise mais enfin on marche
complètement sur la tête donc ça ça oui
c'est quelque chose que moi je regrette
beaucoup on passe au question Internet
et après on est obligé de libérer
Paul Paul qui est déjà très en retard je
je me sens pas prisonnier on
vair donc je prends les questions à la
volé déjà parl mais les questions toutes
les pas toutes bonsoir tout le monde
question comment peut-on inscrire
l'antiorruption
dans Ah ben tu peux arrêter de tpter le
micro merci euh dans les lois et la
Constitution si celle-ci est votée par
des personnes parfois corrompues ou en
conflit
d'intérêts ça c'est aussi c'est un
obstacle important notamment pour le les
réformes qui sont vraiment nécessaires
sur le financement des partis politiques
et des campagnes électorales il se
trouve qu'il y a pas énormément de
volonté politique de changer les lois
dans ce domaine làà comme souvent elles
ont changé après après des scandales je
pense au la loi de 1988 est arrivé dans
dans le contexte du scandale Lucher qui
a qui qui a une un scandale qui est très
intéressant je crois qu'il a Monsieur
rendez-vous avec Monsieur X d'ailleurs
sur le sur le sujet eu donc finalement
on en revient à penser que ce sont les
scandales qui permettent d'avancer les
lois sur des sujets où le législateur
est frileux euh sauf que vous avez vu
méiaap part qui titrait il y a quelques
jours il y a des scandales tous les
jours et tout le monde s'en fout euh
donc il y a quelque chose à jouer sur ça
il faut que l'opinion publique se
mobilise puisque c'est l'indignation de
l'opinion publique qui très souvent
permet de de faire avancer faire avancer
les les lois après anticorp on est
souvent force de proposition on est reçu
au Sénat à l'Assemblée nationale il y a
quand même des choses qui ont été un
tout petit peu amélioré il y a la loi
Sapin 1 la loi Sapin 2 il y a une loi en
2017 qui a moin impact mais qui faut
quand même reconnaître est une loi de
moralisation de la vie publique euh
depuis il y a eu la loi AAP qui est un
recul pour le coup sur la mise en
concurrence dans les marchés publics
donc là récemment à part la loi de
protection des lanceurs d'alertes et
peut-être qu'on peut mettre dedans la
loi contre les la directive contre les
procédures billons euh mais ça ce sont
des des textes européens au niveau de la
France je pense que 2017 il y a pas eu
d'avancé
mais il y a eu une avancée
extraordinaire
laranticor non on a la journée
antiorruption qu'est-ce que c'était
cette journée le
99 c'était quoi ça c'est c'est bah il y
a une journée contre les discrimination
il y a une journée y a beaucoup de il y
a beaucoup de journées il a la fête des
mères F des Pères Noël la journée de
lutte contre la journée internationale
de lutte contre la corruption 32 tweets
32 sur le site du ministère ah oui et
ben super non mais en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que pour nous anticorps
cette journée c'est tous les jours donc
mais c'est vrai et et si vous voulez
queil y a des des des lois qui soi voté
pour que on puisse lutter en amont
contre le phénomène de corruption c'est
évident qu'il faut nous soutenir parce
que nous on fait du lobing ce qu'on a
wanticor.com ouais qu'on du
lobing pardon on fait du lobbing qu'on
appelle du pldoyer donc on Ren compre
comme tu le disaisise des institutionnel
pour leur proposer des modifications de
la loi mais c'est clair que c'est comme
dans les procès si on peut dire qu'on
est 7 70000 700000 on est beaucoup
beaucoup plus fort on est beaucoup
beaucoup mieux écouté donc franchement
si ces sujets vous intéressent vraiment
rejoignez-nous donc quels sont selon
vous les meilleurs moyens pour le
citoyen Landa de participer à ce
combat autre question l'appartement de
Monsieur machin venu Foch les tableaux
vendus par une société un peu louche à
Hong Kong le compte géant à la BNP pour
des affiches de campagne du coup c'est
prescrit tout ça euh non il y a des
allusions de quoi valenttin ouais je
sais pas des tableau vendu à Shanghai à
Hong Kong à Hong Kong je sais pas ah je
sais pas mais en tout cas le monde de
l'art est un est un très bon moyen de de
faire passer de l'argent sal ça c'est
sûr question internet qui n'a pas l'air
d'être une question si c'est une
question bonjour avez-vous pensé à créer
une plateforme en ligne permettant au
citoyen de consulter de manière
extrêmement claire simple et dynamique
comment est attribué l'ensemble de
l'argent public chaque année je pense
que beaucoup de citoyens ne passent pas
à l'action à cause de cette opacité qui
crée de la confusion on n pas toujours
les chiffres c'est pas évident de les
avoir alors vous avez sur les
plateformes publiques les jaunes il y a
les jaunes associatifs il y a plein de
jaunes il y a tout le
budget des ministères mais il y a pas
forcément le détail on est en train de
regarder s'agissant des associations
parce qu'il y a vraiment des
associations qui perçoivent énormément
d'argent public et on se demande parfois
ce qu'elles font par
on sait on se demande pas en tout cas
les informations sont disponibles alors
disponibles de manière
agréable ça je suis j'en suis pas
certaine c'est des tableaux Excel qu'on
peut télécharger mais du coup ça aussi
un avantage qui est que on peut les
exploiter via via la science des
données moi je voulais dire qu' anticorp
en fait c'est il faut faut venir avec ce
que vous avez envie de faire parce que
ce qui est très enrichissant dans une
association citoyenne c'est qu'en fait
tout le monde vient avec sa perception
des chose euh on a des personnes qui
sont venues et qui avaient envie de
faire un jeu de cartes ils ont fait un
jeu de cartes qui s'appelle rend
l'argent c'est super il y a d'autres
personnes qui sont venues avec leur bah
la culture l'amour du cinéma ils ont
fait un festival de corruption c'est
c'est génial aussi on a créé un
anticorps un Data laab euh pour utiliser
la science des données contre la
corruption on vient de terminer là au
mois de novembre une intelligence
artificielle qui est capable de
détecter deux types d'anomalie dans la
passation des marchés publics la
première étant le prix manifestement
supérieur au marché euh qui cache
souvent un financement illégal de
campagne électorale et le second étant
le recours systématique au même
prestataire ce qui nous permet dans
n'importe quelle collectivité
aujourd'hui en France de détecter si une
entreprise a s'est vu attribuer un
nombre excessif de marchés publics donc
on est en train de travailler à outiller
les citoyens à détecter et à se battre
contre la corruption euh et ça c'est des
avancées qui sont qui sont formidables
vraiment et il y a beaucoup de gens qui
nous rejoignent
avec leurs compéten à eux et qui
vraiment nous aident qui se disent waouh
anticors là vous êtes le pot de fer euh
il faut qu'on vous aide et donc qui
viennent nous aider et qui nous apporte
des outils qui sont moi je suis persuadé
que la lutte contre la corruption va va
va vraiment avancer énormément avec la
mise en place de ces outils
d'intelligence artificielle de Big Data
et ainsi de suite oui mais on a aussi
une commission
éducation tous les profs qui veulent
faire une session pédagogique dans leur
collège dans leur lycée peuvent écrire à
éducation
àanticorp.org on a travaillé avec des
personnes du rectorat avec des avec des
profs avec des professionnels de
l'éducation à à créé notamment un jeu de
rôle que les profs peuvent mettre en
place dans leurs classe donc il peuvent
mettre les les élèves en condition de se
dans le rôle et du coup comprendre les
enjeux à plus petite échelle dans une
dans une commune on peut jouer au
mafieux dans sa commune avec un jeu de
carte c'est ça ah ben ça il faut plutôt
prendre en l'argent mais le jeu prend
l'argent et en de nouveau en
modification parce que après rodage on
s'est rendu compte que la corruption
avait tendance à gagner un peu trop et
même si c'est une triste
réalité sur quel pays on peut on devrait
on pourrait s'inspirer pour la lutte
contre la corruption
l'Espagne les pays nordiques les
États-Unis je je sais pas on n pas trop
de modèle j'ai pas comme on fait une
émission documenté j'ai pas les moyens
de je pense que le bon modèle ça devrait
être la
France et donc que c'est au pouvoir
public et ben de faire en sorte que Ben
nous soyons inspirants comme l' par
exemple la Déclaration de 1789 dont on a
déjà parlé
pour les droits et la liberté bien que
le modèle de la lutte en faveur de
l'éthique publique ce soit nous voilà
question internet un antiur pardon
j'allais dire un antiur un anticorps au
niveau Union européenne avec un agrément
de l'Union européenne ou une instance
européenne c'est
possible tu veux répondre il y a pas
besoin partout euh ouais je je suis pas
sûre en fait déjà ça dépend parce que ça
dépend de on vous a expliqué que le
l'agrément il existait parce que le
parquet était pas indépendant il y a
beaucoup de pays de l'Union européenne
dans lequel le parquet est indépendant
après si c'est pour pouvoir saisir le
parquet européen je suis pas sûr que ce
soit ce soit forcément intéressant
intéressant
procéduralement parce que je suis pas
sûr qu'il y ait les mêmes blocages en
fait qui existe il y en a peut-être
d'autres ouais question
internet question internet bonsoir les
faux monayurs sont passibles d'une peine
de perpétu perpétuité car le crime remet
en cause la confiance dans la monnaie
pourquoi les atteintes à la probité qui
remettent en cause la confiance en
l'état ne sont-elles pas punies à la
même de la même manière
elles sont punies assez fortement on a
parlé des peines un petit peu le
favoritisme ces deux ans de prison prise
illégale d'intér c'est 50 prisons oui
mais c'est une autre question qu'elle
soit non mais ça fait style
attention ans oui ça fait plus peur à
grand monde à dire parce que
effectivement elles sont pas appliquées
voil mais les peines de prison qui sont
prévu InAs et moi vous l'avons dit on
est sur 10 ans de de prison pour le la
corruption et le dét fond public c'est
des de prisons qui sont qui sont très
importante et ça dit quelque chose
d'ailleurs on avait regardé 10 ans de
prison c'est la même chose pour trafic
international de drogue c'est ça oui
c'est la même chose que pour même le
viol par exemple qui qu'un crime
extrêmement c'est pas plus que ça le
viol c'est combien bah je crois que
c'est 10 ans s'il y a pas de
circonstances aggravantes si je me
trompe pas mais peut-être que je vais
dire je dis une bêtise mais il me semble
que oui h je c c'est passé à 20 ans
maintenant parce que c'est un CRIM
ouais donc ça marche pas heureusement
euh mais ça marche avec le trafic
international de drogue par exemple ah
si ça marche avec la traite d'être
humain ce qui est complètement fou d' la
traite d'être humain sans aggravante
c'est 7 ans de prison avec une agravante
par exemple sur personnes vulnérables on
est à 10 ans de prison donc la
corruption est réprimé par le Code
[__] autant que la traite d'être
humain fragile mais c'est pour ça que la
difficulté c'est vraiment pas le le
quantum de la peine c'est l'application
en fait de la peine et c'est la durée
des procédures je je vais lire une
question mais on y a déjà répondu ok
vous y avez déjà répondu mais je je vais
je vais me faire plaisir pourquoi ce
sont des associations indépendantes qui
font le travail censé être le travail
des juges indépendants il n'y a plus de
juges ou peut-être qu'ils ne sont plus
indépendants habitons-nous un pays avec
une justice forte avec les faibles et
faible avec les forts
oui moi j'ai j'ai tendance à à croire
que il y a une difficulté de la justice
à à punir les attentat à la probité et
les les les délinquants en col blanc
ouais et alors la question du pourquoi
est très intéressante moi j'ai je crois
qu'en
partie les juges ont tendance à
reconnaître dans les prévenus dans ce
type d'affaires des personnes qui
appartiennent au même au même monde
est culturel et ça c'est c'est très
grave mais de toute façon vous si on
regarde les les States il y a des
rapports il y a des testes qui ont été
écrites sur les décision de justice il y
a aussi un constat assez flagrant que
beaucoup de décisions de justice sont
racistes donc je il y a il y a beaucoup
d'injustice dans la justice mais disons
que prenonsla telle qu'elle est avec les
biais cognitifs que peuvent avoir les
juges il y a soit une incompréhension de
la gravité des sujets de corruption soit
une certaine forme de de tolérance
vis-à-vis de de personnes dont on
t'imagine étant donné leur profil qu'ils
n'ont rien à faire aès en prison et puis
je dirais qu'il y a même une
revendication des politiques de cette
absence d'égalité devant la loi parce
que quand on voit que des députés font
une pétition pour demander que la peine
d'inéligibilité avec exécution
provisoire elle soit pas appliquée à
Marine Le Pen ben en fait pourquoi ces
députés ils font pas en sorte que que
cette loi elle n'existe plus ils sont
députés ils peuvent en FA une autre et
en fait ce qu'ils font c'est qu'ils
demandent à des juges de ne pas
appliquer la loi qu'ils ont voté à
certains de leur père et ça ça n'a
vraiment aucun sens c'est vraiment se
manifester contre l'égalité devant la
loi donc c'est c'est hyper hyper grave
donc autre question Internet vous avez
fini oui parfait je fermé la
bouche quelle limite entre la corruption
active contre des biens entre
parenthèses monétair autres cadeaux au
voyage financer et la cognivance avec
des lobbyistes travaillant pour le
compte d'entreprise privée qui renvoie
la balle des années plus tard comment
définir la corruption oui euh bah c'est
difficile c'est sûr s'il y a cette
question de renvoyer la balle des années
plus tard mais je crois que le texte
permet hein de une appréhension même si
5 ans après ça va être compliqué en fait
la difficulté ça être la preuve Si si la
contrepartie arrive 5 ans plus tard et
forcément c'est beaucoup plus difficile
à prouver donc c'est parce que en
matière de corruption comme en matière
de trafic d'influence il faut démontrer
l'existence d'un pacte de corruption
c'estàd que l'avantage perçu et la
contrepartie du fait pour l'élu pour le
fonctionnaire de faire ou de ne pas
faire quelque chose et c'est vrai que
bon bah il y a généralement pas de mail
qui montrre ça donc en plus s'il y a pas
de concomitance dans les faits ça va
être plus difficile à qualifier
pénalement dire mais il y a plein de
choses qui sont passées depuis 5 ans
mais mais bien sûr que ça arrive aussi
on a des dossiers où on s'est posé la
question
avec un délai délai assez long est-ce
qu'il y a des conflits d'intérêt chez
vous alors je vais répondre si c'est si
vous permettez il peut y avoir des
conflits d'intérêt chez nous nous sommes
citoyens et citoyennes nous avons des
vies par autre que celle de notre
engagement
bénévole nous avons des familles des
proches et donc il peut y avoir des
conflits d'intérêt comme pour tout le
monde et dans nos statut il y a une
disposition qui interdit que ces conf
intérêt soit matérialisé soit
cristallisé donc nous prévenons les
conflits d'intérêts c'est-à-dire que moi
si j'ai un par exemple je suis
universitaire et bien je dois déclarer
que je travaille dans telle université
si elise est avocate il est hors de
question que nous ayons un dossier qui
viendrait à favoriser l'un l'un ou l'une
de ses clientes euh Ines a une famille
nous n'allons pas prendre un dossier
pour faire plaisir à la famille d'Ines
euh nous donc nous veillons à prévenir
les conflits d'intérêt et je dirais même
plus que nous les prévenons au carré
pour la raison que nous devons être
encore plus
exemplaire parce que nous prenons
l'exemplarité pour les autres ce qui
veut dire que pour nous-mêmes nous
devons être absolument irréprochable ce
qui n'est pas facile bien évidemment ce
qui demande une attention de chaque
instant mais ce qui est parfaitement
normal eu égard à notre objet social
donc oui il peut y avoir des conflit
d'intérêt mais ces conflits d'intérêts
ne n'entravent pas le fonctionnement de
notre association ils sont en quelque
sorte euh désactivés ils sont par les
les mécanismes de prévention que nous
mettons en œuvre il sont dévitalisés
qu'est-ce qui est plus carré c'est
cubique je vais lire un commentaire euh
faisant référence à ça et vous allez
tous me répondre ok bon bonsoir l'équipe
Élise en tant que présidente d'anticorps
alors c'est plus le cas il y a très
longtemps peut-elle répondre aux
accusations du conflit d'intérêt supposé
par ran Branco
hervera si oui quell mesures ont été
pris pour garantir la transparence et
regagner la confiance des contributeur
comme moi qui ont cessé leur soutien à
cause de ces
doutes ce seul élément permet de
démontrer qu'encore aujourd'hui
anticorps blast et Denis Robert je sais
pas ce que c'est ça ça c'est un extrait
un extrait d'un site
internetors ils font référence à
quoi alors déjà je pense qu'il a il
continue à soutenir anticorps et moi
écouter monsieur Bronco mais euh à
l'époque j'ai fait l'objet de plein
d'accusations de Monsieur Branco qui
dans la presse
m'a accusé d'être mafieuse carrément he
et qui a été mise pour diffamation pas
diffamation non insulte publique M pas
quand on fait 30 HE de bénévola par
semaine en fait on a plus l'énergie pour
faire des plaintes en diffamation dans
tous les sens mais il y a une décision
de justice qui a é rendu contre la
personne sur la base
laquelle monsieur Branco fondait son
accusation et c'était en début d'année
2024 et en fait la juridiction a
à écrit noir sur blanc qu'il avait fait
un montage c'estàd qu'il a utilisé ma
voix et il l'a monté pour me faire dire
à chouette à un moment où je sais pas il
disait il disait que il y avait un
montage qui permettait l'évasion c ou
quelque chose comme ça et donc il y av
ma voix qui fait ah chouette bien
évidemment j'ai jamais répondu ça et
c'était un montage qui est interdit par
la loi on n pas le droit de faire
ça donc ça on a une décision de justice
qui le qui le dit je crois que cette
personne a fait appel donc on aura une
décision
d'appel peut-être en début 2025
d'ailleurs et ce qui m'était reproché
par Monsieur Branco c'est en fait
d'avoir
présenté un
donateur qui donnait de l'argent à
l'association de l'avoir présenté à
blast est-ce que c'est un conflit
d'intérêt euh je réfléchis euh moi j'ai
jamais euh j'ai jamais été intéressé aux
résultats de de Blast he dans le sens il
y a pas de d'actionnaire dans ce dans ce
média donc que blast s'écroule ou pas je
gagne pas d'argent ou ou pas d'argent et
à vra dire le projet que nous avait
présenté euh ce donateur enfin son sa
motivation c'était un média
d'investigation euh contre la corruption
donc je pense pas que ce soit ça ce soit
en conflit d'intérêt avec anticorps au
contraire parce que on a beaucoup parlé
de lanceur d'alerte mais en fait on a on
a aussi énormément besoin de médias
d'investigation pour sortir les affaires
de corruption parce que beaucoup de
plaintes à anticorps sont basés sur un
travail d'investigation journalistique
que que nous on fait pas par ailleurs
voilà je sais pas si la la réponse est
est satisfaisante ou pas vous enquétez
sur les plateformes de crypto basé au
Bahamas qui servirait à nettoyer les
fonds non vous en avez entendu parler
non non euh une dernière question
internet je vais la
prendre à à la voler au hasard allez
bonjour si on est témoin de la
corruption d'un de nos élus quel
cheminement conseillez-vous jeen ai
confiance en plus grand monde ah ben moi
je conseille de nous écrire à nous
écrire à Anticor soit à l'adresse
expertise juridique an
atanticorp.org qui reçoit toutes les
alertes et qui les analyse soit de
lancer une alerte sur notre site de
manière coder si on a besoin de plus de
conf chiffrer euh chiffrer exactement je
vous ai dit chiffrer tout à l'heure si
on a besoin de plus de confencialité je
vous ai dit que cétais vraiment pas
informaticienne mais je vous rassure les
informaticiens qui disent ouis je
confonds les deux non non mais c'est
c'est vraiment chiffré et voilà je je
conseille de de nous de venir vers nous
après vous avez aussi la possibilité
bien sûr de saisir directement un
procureur de la public qui vous répondra
et qui fera ce qui pourra faire de votre
de votre plainte après nous on permet
aux citoyens enfin déjà on leur apporte
un soutien juridique parce que on
analyse les faits et on les caractérise
pénalement ce qui permet que les
plaintes elles soient déjà un peu plus
on va dire formalisé et puis qu'elles
aient voilà elle elles soit plus en
mesure de convaincre les procureurs de
la République donc ça c'est important et
puis après nous on a le joker de
l'agrément c'est-à-dire que si jamais il
y a une infraction et qu'il y a quand
même un classement sans suite on a la
possibilité de saisir un juge donc je
pense que ça peut être intéressant et
aussi le fait que ce soit anticorps qui
porte le dossier c'est aussi une
protection parfois pour les lanceurs
d'alertes qu'on pe envie de mettre leur
nom dans une procédure ça bien sûr on
peut leur apporter nous aussi cette
protection et donc là j'en arrive à
cette autre question qui n'est pas une
question au départ mais qui est un
commentaire il faera peut-être assurer
cette personne avec son commentaire mais
la dernière partie de la question pas
piquer deson
ah je lis pour quelle raison vous ne
dites pas clairement que la justice est
CLA corrompu par la classe politique
quand il s'agit de traiter des affaires
comme celles que vous avez cité
précédemment subissez-vous des pressions
personnelles je vais répondre on ne
subit aucune pression pas comme en
Italie je connais pas la situation
italienne mais à titre personnel je
subis aucune pression et de toute façon
je vois pas quel type de pression je je
pourrais subir par ailleurs nous sommes
petit attentat à la bombe nous sommes
une équipe nous sommes extrêmement
solidaires et et surtout nous respectons
euh les institutions nous respectons la
justice nous respectons la présomption
d'innocence nous respectons les
personnes nous respectons les bien donc
en réalité nous menons une action qui
est tout simplement d'intérêt général
voilà vous avez fait votre
testement trop
triste non j'ai pas fait mon pas peur
d'emploisonnement dans un avion des
choses comme ça écoute si ça arrive un
jour par exemple dans votre association
s'il y a un membre qui par exemple qui
disparaî
un petit peu subitement moi c'est jamais
arrivé depuis 20 ans bon on on spécule
énormément du coup ce qui arrive c'est
les pression de l'administration parfois
moi j'ai eu trois précrôles fiscaux on a
déjà parl en 2021 je crois qui sont très
bien terminés parfaitement oui j'étais
remboursé dans les trois cas donc
c'était même
rentable pour
moiou mais je pense à Eric altt qui a
été viceprésentanticorp pendant
longtemps qui est un magistrat qui a été
mis en cause à l'intérieur de son
administration on lui a refusé d'avoir
abusé de sa liberté d'expression donc il
a eu quand même tout un un débat assez
tendu en fait finalement en disant
est-ce qu'il faut que la maison justice
reste reste aux ordre est-ce bien gardé
ou est-ce que il y a une liberté
d'expression des magistrats et des juges
est-ce qu'un magistrat et un juge doit
vivre en dehors de la cité ouce qu'elle
a son droit de citoyen qui lui permet
aussi d'être quelqu'un de militant et
d'engager et finalement euh cette cette
cette inspection a n'a mené à rien mais
on a mobilisé des des personnes dans
tous les sens qui se sont déplacé dans
le sud de la France pour interroger
Jean-Christophe Picard que vous avez
reçu sur ce plateau aussi donc pass
bonjour d'ailleurs tout d'un coup on
diligente des moyens incroyables pour
reprocher à un magistrat de s'est
exprimer contre la corruption donc
contre une infraction pénale alors même
que la justice est sous-financée et
c'est peu c'est peu de le dire elle est
asphyiée carrément et moi je vous dis je
vous ai dit à plusieurs reprises dans
cette dans cette émission que je pense
qu'il faut pas généraliser il faut il
faut jamais généraliser parce que quand
on généralise on arrête d'essayer de
comprendre on arrête de se battre et euh
non la justice est pas corrompu
franchement je pense même pas qu'on ait
jamais eu un cas de corruption la
justice alors que on serait compétent
euh en vertu de notre agrément je pense
même qu'il y a que la justice qui arrête
le pouvoir donc au contraire il faut
défendre la justice et il faut euh en
faire un sujet de société pour que la
justice soit d'avantage financée parce
que ça c'est un choix politique c'est
magnifique une conclusion pareil c'est
magnifique tu as faim toi
non il faut dire à vos éuditeurs
auditrices qu'il est 9h20 oui et que je
devais vous ler 21h20
20h45 ça tombe bien on a éclusé beaucoup
de questions Internet est-ce que vous
avez trois livres à conseiller à notre
communauté chacun et un conseil pour les
jeunes générations chacun avant que je
vous rel alors pour les jeunes
générations il faut lire éise
ise com comment pour les jeunes
générations je me permets de conseiller
de lire l'un desmodable et très actuel
1984 de George Arwell c'est un livre
absolument intemporel pour les jeunes
génération je me permet de consil dire
le très actuel et indémodable ouvrage de
Evi qui s'appelle la corruption de la
République qui date de 1992 que j'ai
étudié à l'époque et qui m'a vraiment
beaucoup marqué et enfin pour donner une
note d'espoir de joie peut-être un bon
petit romain gar voilà la promesse de
l'aube quel beau titre pour finir une
émission comme la vôtre euh moi j'ai
recommandé de lire une enquête qui est
sortie il y a peu de temps cette année
il me semble qui est rapace qui concerne
la corruption dans le sud de la France
ellise je conseille ton tract tu peux
pas autoconseiller ton bouquin le tract
anticorps le tract galimar desis est-ce
que je peux le voir il est où il
est des Lisbon benan et alt don elle ne
perçoit pas les droits d'auteur zéro
droits d'auteur donc ça les droits
d'auteurs sont versés à l'association
donc c'est aussi un moyen de la soutenir
ouais et bah en dehors du sujet de
corruption moi je je conseille toujours
de lire Delbo et c'est ta trilogie sur
sur la la Choa qui est en fait un livre
sur l'engagement et avec vraiment la
littérature et et même de la poésie et
qui permet en fait de voir le sort qui
est réservé aux personnes qui s'engag et
c'est hyper important de le rappeler je
pense bah de nos jours
ise pendant que Paul prépare son conseil
pour les jeunes générations TR livres
oui ben moi comme la dernière fois je
vais pas vous conseiller des lectures
sur la corruption parce que je lis pour
penser à autre chose j'ai ru récemment
le cavalier suédois qui est une lecture
absolument
magnifique je vous conseille aussi de
lire laordre du contrevant qui est aussi
un un bouquin absolument magnifique et
le 3è un homme Oriana
falaci Paul un conseil pour les jeunes
générations une bouteille à la mer
quelque chose d'impérissable qui restera
sur les réseaux
engagez-vous alors moi je je rebondis
sur engagez-vous ne croyez pas que
l'engagement c'est uniquement le
mutantisme l'engagement c'est aussi une
position dans le monde c'estàdire c'est
être ouvert regarder autour de soi
regarder si les gens qu'on croise tous
les jours n'ont pas besoin d'aide n'ont
pas besoin d'attention parfois juste une
minute pour aider son voisin tout ça à
mon sens c'est vraiment de l'engagement
et c'est ce qui permet de dans une
société bien plus agréable et bien plus
juste avant de donner la parole à Elise
est-ce que vous êtes Cato non pas du
tout vous avez reçu une éducation Cato
c'est c'est un peu Cato ce que je viens
de dire non c'est très Cato euh ben je
suis absolument pas Cato je suis
extrêmement Laï et je je suis de suis
d'une famille pas du tout religieuse
mais par contre je pense qu'il y a
certainement des valeurs dans le
catholicisme qui sont très belles on
peut pas le nier donc ça c'est pas de
problème avec ça tu ne voleras point
c'est ça ben non mais l'argent public
l'argent public moi aussi c'est le c ce
que je vais dire mais bon faut dire que
les taxes sont sont pas mal dans leur
principe B oui eu je je trouve que dans
la société on pense de moins en moins
collectif ou oui et c'est un drame en
fait le sujet de la corruption
évidemment c'est un sujet collectif
puisque on a parlé de corruption de
service public d'accès de tous à des
services publics de qualité c'est une
façon de de penser collectivement alors
que les personnes qui se rendent
coupables d'actes de corruption ils font
exactement le contraire ils sont
individualistes et ils veulent
s'accaparer pour
eux de l'argent ou des biens qui
appartiennent à la collectivité et je
crois qu'il faut vraiment se battre
contre contre cette résurgence qui
m'inquiète vraiment ces dernières années
de l'individualisme c'est c'est beau
d'être collectif et puis surtout je
pense qu'on est mieux individuellement
quand on est pour le collectif Infiné
donc il y a aussi un intérêt à à jouer à
jouer en équipe mesdames et monsieurs on
vous remercie d'être venu aujourd'hui au
pied levé d'ailleurs on avait une une
interview géopolitique avec un très haut
calibre qui a été décalé reporté à la
rentrée parce que la situation
géopolitique est tellement hardcore même
pour eux que ça devient compliqué et il
nous fallait un sujet d'actualité et de
fond et donc la corruption merci d'avoir
été là on sera très heureux de vous
recevoir en 2025 si vous avez besoin de
discuter de ce qui se passe de votre
association et on vous souhaite un bon
courage et merci Merci à VOUS trop
chette
[Musique]